e
welcome to the Monday March 3rd meeting
of the science technology and energy
committee we have three public hearings
this morning and this afternoon we'll be
gathering for an executive session on
five
bills or four bills
actually as is our custom I'd ask you
all to rise and join representative
Corman as he leads us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
Al to the flag of the United States of
America and to the for stands Nation
all okay so the first bill we'll hear
this morning is House Bill
266 relative to structural changes to
the Department of energy and I'll call
on the Bill's Prime sponsor
representative Harrington to introduce
this
legislation good morning um thank you
for allowing me to present this bill Mr
chairman uh HB 266 is as it says
relatives a structural change es in the
department of energy this is part of the
ongoing transition that started with the
last budget Bill uh where we spun off a
new Department of energy and took some
of the responsibilities that were under
the Pu and put them with that department
uh this bill was submitted uh by myself
at the request of the Department of
energy and there seems to be some um
problems that are being uh discussed
between both the Pu and the department
of energy and rather than going into the
specifics myself I think it would be
best if they explain their own positions
and then we might decide where we want
ah head with this bill so unless there
are questions I think you should
probably hold them for the uh people
from the Department of energy and the
Public Utilities
Commission I'll take okay thank you for
that bill introduction seeing no
questions for representative Harrington
we'll call next on the department of
energy since they requested this bill
and asked Chris Elms and David shulock
bill good morning and welcome back good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record Chris Elms and
David shulock from the Department of
energy sorry about
that so uh the dep Department of energy
requested House Bill 266 which we say uh
see as a natural continuation of the
creation of the Department of energy
from back in 2021 and one that we see as
removing some of the guard rails related
to the restructuring that we think at
this point are no longer necessary and
are are more likely to be harmful than
helpful uh I do want to be clear upfront
I intend to talk about open pu
proceedings and it's very possible that
the discussion will touch on information
that is not in the record in those
proceedings my discussion of these
issues is important for me to discuss
this legislation before you
today so as many of you know I was
around and very involved in the state
budget in 2021 that created the
department of energy and that
restructured the
Pu the intent of the restructuring
included two important goals we wanted
to separate the regulatory advocacy and
energy policymaking role from the role
of adjudicating compliance with utility
regulation and we wanted to finally give
elected officials the governor the
executive Council and the legislature
control over energy policy by having an
agency that is accountable to them
consistent with this attent the
legislature gave the department the
regulatory advocacy and policy-making
role and the Pu the adjudicative role
unfortunately it seems clear from our
experience our observation and our
discussions that the Pu wants a
relationship between itself and the
department that is contrary to the
legislative
intent uh it seems apparent that the Pu
wants to control the way the department
does its job including what proceedings
the department devotes its resources to
how the department conducts its review
of utility filings and proceedings and
what information or evidence it provides
the Commission in those proceedings I
know we want to keep this you know uh
short so I will say that we have met
with the Pu to try and see if we could
resolve some of the uh the differences
that we have and come to an agreement
prior to this uh public hearing what
we've seen sections 3 four and five seem
to be non-controversial and more or less
reflect the status quo as it is today uh
section two of the bill uh appeared to
be the primary area of concern
specifically the Striking of online 8 uh
be a party to all
proceedings uh the intent there that
that would clarify that the department
has the ability to decide which cases we
will participate in uh the commission
expressed their view that that legally
they need a counterparty in all
proceedings no matter how small or
straightforward and uh if the doe
wouldn't participate they would have to
either staff up or transfer some
responsibilities to some entity like the
doj and look we obviously disagree we
wouldn't have put it in otherwise uh I
do think it's kind of a red herring
argument um it is possible that they're
right uh we really don't think they are
I think there are examples to show that
I think there are n numerous statutory
instances where hearings are not
required for the Pu and I think even the
site evaluation committee is one example
where we see that the state is
authorized but not required to act as a
counterparty in adjudication through the
council uh for the public at the
doj
um so I have reached a point in my
testimony where I wanted to explain why
we think this provision was uh important
and I wanted to give you some examples
from pending dockets um I'm looking back
I see that the Pu is still here and I I
have to say I think that that is
relative
uh Reckless after the disclaimer that I
gave uh that I would be talking about
pending dockets with information not on
the record um I have to think of it as
an attempt to stop me from discussing uh
the issues that I think you need to hear
I know the risk to rap payers uh if the
Pu is forced to recuse themselves uh
from from the dockets I want to talk
about or if their decision is overturned
on appeal because they sat here uh among
other cases I wanted to discuss the
eversource and Liberty electric rate
cases and between us the consumer advoc
vate and the companies we've probably
spent $3 million just to put on the
cases um and and rars will probably have
to pay most of that so you know I think
in the past I've seen most pu
Commissioners would leave the room when
a potential discussion on pending
dockets uh with information not on the
record uh would be coming up um I think
it shows that they they think it's more
important to hear what Chris Elms has to
say than for you to hear what I have to
say um but but if you want give me a
call
um I I I just I really can't risk uh you
know these these cases getting thrown
out so let's be clear uh this this
disregard of the legislature is exactly
what this bill is trying to address uh
and if they if they had fiscal concerns
related to the section that were real uh
they wouldn't be risking more than my
agency's entire regulatory Support
Division annual budget uh by sitting
here but look that being said since
section two uh is what the Pu objected
to we offered to concede on that point
we were and are totally willing to
accept an amendment that would get rid
of the strike through on line 8 and the
addition on line 10 we can provide
language uh for that Amendment and so
just the addition on line 10 so you know
what I'm referring to is the sentence in
which the department files a notice of
participation you'd probably have to add
an and after proceedings on line 8 um
but that should address the
concerns uh related to section two
however the Pu told us they didn't like
that proposal uh and that rejection to
me has made it abundantly clear that the
pu's real issue goes all the way back to
2021 um because they are unwilling to
accept the five little words on line
five quote as determined by the
department and that and that section
would make it clear that it is the
Department of energy who who determines
what we put into the record of evidence
before the Pu you know uh it does feel
like rejecting that means that the Pu
sees themselves as controlling
everything uh related to energy they
insist that they get to determine what
we submit to them as evidence not just
to decide the cases that are based on
the evidence that has been put before
them uh you know I I I understand sort
of the Pu wanting to cling to the old
ways they had a lot of power prior to
2021 Independence they got to dictate
everything and I know how hard it is uh
when you have that power to give it up
and and you know obviously the chairman
came in under the old old system
commissioner chatapati was there for a
long time as an analyst and we've heard
that that commissioner Delano grew up
immersed in the practices and framework
of the old pu in their presentation
we've talked about how things have been
for the last 100 years but four years
ago things changed and the legislature
said that they didn't want unelected and
unaccountable bureaucrats to control
everything related to energy policy I
think concerns about resources related
to this section are a red herring this
bill does not have a fiscal impact and I
think it is fair to ask whether the Pu
feels underresourced because they are
trying to do the job they wish they had
rather than the job they were intended
to have by the legislature the change on
line five is vital to the independent
functioning of the department and
fulfills the most important goals of the
legislature when it restructured the
commission and created the department we
must preserve the Department's
accountability to elected officials and
to the Pu or not not and not to the Pu
let me be clear uh if if there are
further discussions a subcommittee or
something that has to happen uh we're
happy to participate in continue
discussions but with our suggested
Amendment we think the bill is ready to
Department representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr Elms
for taking my question um so in looking
at at the language uh that you refer to
the highlighted language I had uh two
questions first you said um that you
thought on line five that there was an
opposition and I'm sure they can speak
to it when they come up to line fives as
determined by the department is that um
a shift
in uh how policies are currently
executed can somebody answer that for me
so I mean the entire uh statement is the
department shall have the authority to
investigate any matter related
to uh the statutes that it administers
which is new or that may come before the
Public Utilities Commission and to
appear before the commission to advocate
for the Department's position and for
the purposes of providing a record for
consideration by the commission as
determined by the department so is that
really a shift in who's doing that work
I I don't think we see that as a shift
as much as a clarification of the way
things should be operating and we just
that should be absolutely crystal clear
that the department determines what the
department provides as
evidence okay that's a good
clarification that makes sense thank you
and can I have a followup followup so my
other question was related to line 18
where you refer to RSA 21g 10 um Mr
shulock can you answer for us what that
RSA is is that a that's a definitional
uh portion of the statute 21 G10 um
describ
the responsibilities that a department
has towards any um attached agency and
it you know it's basically back office
support so that you're not
duplicating and can I have a follow up
on that question to Mr shulock yes go
ahead thank you just following my line
of questioning so uh I guess my question
would be then I know that there's been a
a real uh shift in resources from how
things were configured prior to 2021 and
creating the DOE and so the question
would be around
um uh that allocation of resources and
whether there's any difference between
an agency that's attached to the
Department of energy and a regulatory
body because I I know we talked a lot in
2021 about the bright red line and I
think having the resources sort of
switched over and now you know allocated
to it it kind of blurs the line of of
how that work happening so if you could
speak to that that would be great so the
the bright red line had to do with
Communications between the Departments
and you know part of the goal of that
initial legislation was to find
efficiencies right and um if the the way
that that line was interpreted was that
we could not even speak on
administrative matters anytime we wanted
to say can our staff use the downstairs
bathroom we had to go to the Department
of Justice the Department of Justice had
to talk about it they would talk to the
Pu the Pu would talk to the Department
of Justice and then they would talk to
us over those simple administrative
things and so uh that bright red line
was adjusted so that the only time that
we're not not really permitted to talk
to each other uh is when there is a
contested case uh being adjudicated
before the Public Utilities Commission
and we're a party um and we're always a
party under the current statute
um and so we couldn't have behind the
scenes talks with the Commissioners
about that docket and and that is now
the bright red line it's not as broad as
all administrative
matters but I I will say that this
section section three is really designed
to clarify what's sort of been happening
in practice especially uh as the as the
restructuring has become settled it's
important to remember that the that
there was not a reduction in staff
related to regulatory support when the
department was
uh there there were uh six senior
advisor positions provided to the Pu
very high level positions um and and
some of those folks could be attorneys
some of those folks could be analysts uh
providing that advisory staff to the
commission Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question just for my own
uh
clarification involving line five those
those words as determined by the
department could you explain how the
department determines that in is it
unilateral is it is it is it a committee
of of um people uh is the Pu involved uh
how's they determined yeah absolutely so
I will say the buck stops with the
commissioner uh as far as the department
goes and obviously we're an executive
branch agency and we you know report to
the governor um but you know in terms of
our process and developing these things
there is there's an collaborative
approach we have uh you know staff who
will Who will talk things out we'd like
to encourage and Foster debate between
folks uh and generally we are able to
find positions that work for everybody
and work for the Department obviously if
there are disputes the as I said the
commissioner additional
questions representative rolds has
one thank you Mr chairman um thank you
for being here uh again circling back to
that section four between line lines two
and line
five have there been
instances and could you cite a could you
give us some examples to to better
understand uh what this is aiming at
resolving
where the department has appeared before
the commission and advocated and
presented you know information anal is
and yet and and then it seems like
you've been told by the
commission
um that's not enough we'd like
more
um is that what's going on between the
two
bodies I'm going to let uh my general
counsel talk I do want to be clear that
I'm not I I I I really don't want to
talk about pending dockets all the
commission's here so I'm gonna let let
David try to you want that
okay but uh yes that's generally what
this is getting at so these these
Provisions act sort of like a new bright
over so when the commission when the
staff moved to the department part of
the reason for that was the executive
didn't want the commission controlling
that staff and what the staff presented
right and that line has been blurred by
the commission by the way that they've
interpreted uh and applied these
Provisions by trying to essentially tell
the department what the department
should present and in some cases
ordering them to present information to
to the
commission right um and they
they no longer have the control over
that staff they have their own staff
that they can send to to do you know
certain tasks right so
this sort of draws that line the the
commissioner of the Department of energy
controls his staff they control theirs
and we decide what we present to them
they decide what they do with it right
so okay thank you are questions for the
Department
representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I'm I'm trying to
figure out a a succinct way to
characterize what you see as the duties
of the puc versus the duties of the
department and I think commissioner Elms
or Deputy Commissioner Elms uh said that
at the beginning but I didn't quite
catch the actual uh characterization so
I I believe that the PC is adjudicative
is there more to it and then uh what is
what is how would you describe the Doe's
purview in a small number of words sure
um you know I think for the role of the
puc I believe that the reorganized pu
was uh intended to objectively decide
matters that come before it uh we
believe that the Pu is intended to make
decisions either uh either upon an
application made by a regulated utility
uh with its supporting information or on
a record established by the parties
before it uh in a contested case uh it's
up to the Department of energy to you
know uh advocate for the public interest
and to provide the record uh that that
we see fit that the record of evidence
in those
cases follow
up thank
you in terms of enforcement
issues is that solely in the doe or does
the Pu have any responsibility for
enforcement um the Pu would be the body
to um order fines actually be paid so
the the department may see a violation
of ruler statute uh we would work with
uh utility to end that violation and in
cases where it was necessary uh we would
uh petition the commission to
fine right or to you know maybe issue
Thomas you weren't finished I'm I'm
sorry again in that case they would be
adjudicating what whether the fine
should take place that's their basic
function
yeah representative Thomas um thank you
um so in reading this bill it says that
you have the authority to investigate
any matter matters related to the
statutes it administers um as determined
by the department the uh full party
status and right to appeal these sound
like new um responsibilities for the doe
and in your testimony you did say that
you would need to staff up and yet you
also said there was no fiscal impact can
you please explain that sure and and
thank you I'll take the first the the
last part first uh and I I apologize if
I misspoke what I I wanted to make clear
is that we we don't think anybody would
have to staff up as associated with this
bill that we don't see there being any
fiscal impact uh in section four the the
line provide documents and other
materials to um you know you know that
that part of of that just wants to make
clear that the authorities that we have
uh related to companies before pu
proceedings also applies to our
statutory jurisdictions where the Pu
isn't involved one example would be like
our Dig Safe program where we want to
make sure we just have the the those
same authorities with with utilities
even if it's not a proceeding going for
the PC and and David's going to correct
what I what I said there no that's
exactly right but I would give SEC
enforcements uh as another example
because that's not technically the Pu
that goes before the P the the SEC even
though all three Commissioners are on
the SEC and it's administratively
attached so we just need to make sure
that we have the authorities that we
need and the the SEC enforcement uh
Provisions were added after the
reorganization so that is new right okay
thank
you further
questions seeing none we'll get the
other side of the story now and invite
the Public Utilities Commission to come
goldner good morning chairman Vose and
honorable members of the committee I'm
PC chairman Dan goldner here with the
fellow Commissioners prip
chop and Mark Delano and Senior advisor
Sarah
Fuller the uh the puc is not opposed to
the de's proposal woven through
different sections of the bill to make
the de uh the D's analytical support
available to the Pu on a contingent
basis at the election of the doe though
to our knowledge this would be a unique
approach in US utility
regulation to support this model the
commission would need to enhance our own
analytical Staffing If This eventuality
Were to come to
pass as there would be no certainty that
truly independent non- Monopoly
analytical advice and positions would be
available to use in our
proceedings while we don't yet know this
scope of doe participation given the
current analytical resourcing three in
the Pu and 13 in the doe with additional
staff attorneys to support the
analysis this change would involve
significant additional resources and
require an expenditure of additional
funds over budget estimates and GNC
approval the commission also does not
object to the Doe's proposal that the
administrative support to be provided to
the commission under our a 12p be paired
back to the basic package offered by RSA
21 G10 which is was mentioned earlier is
basically budgeting and back office
functions like billing and ordering of
supplies the commission would further
recommend that this change presented in
section three of the bill be modified so
the commission would no longer be
administratively attached to the doe as
we can handle these simple
Affairs the commission stands ready to
work with Das to launch contingency
planning for the severance of the
administrative support relationship with
the de and we recommend that section
three of the bill be amended to delete
references to the PC in Romans 6 and 7
of RSA 12 P5 and there would also by the
way be changes required at
363 and 365 to address assessments and
Staffing thank you for your time this
concludes my remarks and we're available
for questions
Pu representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman good morning morning thanks for
being here um okay so thank you for your
testimony um and as far as section three
goes did I understand you to say that
you would like to see that the um that
section stricken for um the attachment
of the Public Utilities Commission to to
being within the doe as it is currently
structured or as they're proposing it to
be structured yes and the basic answer
to that is that under RSA 21 G10 those
functions that are remaining the pie
they're very straightforward functions
and we can handle that easily within our
current administrative Staffing and
followup followup okay so um so you you
also said though that because there are
13 people who can do invest instigations
in doe but three in the Pu that you
might need to hire additional people so
I'm trying to reconcile in my mind if
you ended up no longer being attached um
administratively uh how would that
affect your budget in terms of the other
uh you said objective research because
you didn't want to rely on the Monopoly
research so I guess I'm what I'm trying
to figure out is do you see your role as
um seeking more information beyond what
the stakeholders bring to you in an
adjudicative
proceeding um because it sounds like you
don't necessarily trust the information
you're getting
from the utilities or who the the
professionals that are trying to bring
you information okay I think that was a
multi-part question let me they always
are with me I'm sorry let me try to
address it first things first so first
in section three which talks about
administrative support that's very
straightforward and and we can handle
that with with current Staffing uh
sections one and two um are uh
substantive they're analysts uh lawyers
attached to the analysts to to bring
forward um information and in uh in
those cases we would need additional
resources so one and two more resources
three no more
resources and I think you might have was
there more that I should answer on
that um I'm not sure representative
McGee was there something else you
wanted to know well I I I think I
understand that one and two are
different but so one and two maintain
the relationship right where
you're kind of um reliant on the
department of Energy's resources is that
right yeah let me thank you for
reminding me on that so what happens
before the puc if you can uh picture uh
this so the three PU Commissioners are
are sitting at a
table and then the uh Department today
is always before us as an automatic
party per the current legislation the um
the Monopoly the utility is is is almost
always there as the movement because
they want to change their rates the OCA
very often participates in our dockets
as well and then there are also um other
parties interveners uh special interests
that also often participate in the
dockets um so the case before us if we
only have as a mandatory or automatic
party the Monopoly the regulated utility
then we as chairman voice just
highlighted in this particular issue we
only have one side of the story we we
the commission does not have access to
Discovery um so we are very limited in
what we can get if the state uh does not
is not represented
in our Doc and and let me just quickly
add one more thing in the SEC which was
mentioned earlier there is an automatic
party today the council for the public
from the doj is an automatic party and a
mandatory party to all SEC proceedings
and so that is uh that's how the SEC is
set
up okay follow up I do have a follow up
on that okay so now that's thank you for
um outlining that I'm sure that's
helpful for a lot of people that haven't
had experience at the Pu but it sounds
like in the proceedings you do have uh
intervenor stakeholders who also present
additional evidence and perspective
correct that that's correct but not in
all cases I would say that um I didn't
uh I couldn't give you a percentage off
hand but I would say
interveners and um inter interveners or
maybe participate in this is off the top
of my head maybe 20% of the dockhead
something like that it's usually there
aren't interveners in the
you further questions representative
Harrington uh thank you and thank you
for taking my question I think just to I
get this down into a nutshell then is
the main dis aren't you the prime
sponsor that's right I am not supposed
to ask questions sorry about that yes
he's the prime sponsor he can't answer
qu ask questions representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um would this if
this bill was to pass would it us
overall speed up the process the docket
flow in the p in the Pu or help aid
that yeah I think it would slow it down
um we would somehow have to get the
information that we're seeking in order
to you know we're the Arbiter between
the customer and the regulated utility
so if just the regulated utility is is
on that balance scale then we somehow
have to get the other perspective so it
would slow down we would either have to
um find the resources elsewhere whether
I don't know exactly how we would do it
that depends on the outcome of the
legislation but we would somehow have to
reflect the interest of the customer on
scale representative bernardy has a
question thank you Mr chairman so so why
is it that you don't think the doe is
bringing the contrary opinion if there
is one that's appropriate
I I think today they're an automatic and
mandatory party and they participate in
in all the dockets and they do they do
bring the information forward that is
extremely helpful and helps the
commission balance the interests of the
customer and the regulated utility this
legislation would change that
relationship and make it um optional for
the Department to
participate followup follow up so if the
department of energy is uh making the
assessment that the that the uh issues
in the docket really don't require uh
you know additional um contrary or
substantive uh information to be
provided why why are you distrusting
that
decision good morning I'm Sarah Fuller
um for the Pu so so the commission
doesn't submit evidence we don't submit
evidence or to our hearings as everybody
has said we are the Arbiter we are the
we are the fact finders so in
order we can't read into the
non-participation that they have done
something that would be a determination
on something that's not in front of us
so just to go take your point a little
further if we are to assume which I
think the department of energy um has
asked us to do if they're not
participating that they have reviewed
everything and it all looks kosher that
is taking some that is taking a fact
that is not evidence uh into the matter
and making that
determination so you can't you you can't
read in to the record what their
non-participation could mean because as
um Deputy Commissioner Elm said those
decisions are made on a on a number of
factors you know commissioner coin makes
those determinations with his staff what
they are and are not going to
participate in so we can't read into
non-appearance anything other than the
fact that we have one side at one table
and there's nobody on the other side and
we do not have the ability to submit our
own evidence we are not a party the the
bright red line took the party status
away and so the only parties in those
case would be the public the utility
were regulating and in those
circumstances yes we have um just gone
through rul making and we have added
some uh commission information requests
but if you read through our rules even
commission information requests are not
evidence until those questions are asked
at hearing and um it comes on the record
so there are some tools that the
commission can ask questions um but it's
not a party status and there's no
Discovery and we don't uh we don't
get our own evidence so I think
question yes okay repres representative
Swanson has a
question I'm sorry I withdraw my
question Mr chair representative Corman
has a question thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh
Deputy Commissioner Elms suggested that
he'd be okay with uh removing the
changes in line so that the be a party
to all proceedings would remain in
statute and removing the bolded text in
line
10 uh so I gather that actually conforms
with your view am I correct so I I'll
take it I'll take the first stab at this
and then I'll go to the chair so we had
very um we had discussions with the um
Department beforehand and we sat and we
talked and this was in the issue is that
with line five as determined by the
department I think that means that
although the you know the department if
if we take out the changes in two but
department there's no the department can
come and and just say uh we chose to not
do X Y and Z in this matter and have no
questions for any of the witnesses
and so to us it seemed like a
disingenuous offer um to take out two
but to leave in the line five if you're
going to if you're going to participate
you participate and even if you don't
take a
position you know there's generally some
level of Discovery and I think that when
you read when you read line five it
could just mean that they're literally
sitting at the table um and and to us it
seemed or to me it seems uh like
slightly a disingenuous offer to to take
five follow up thank you so I I just
want to be really clear here um so
you're suggesting uh removing the bolded
text don't don't do the change that's in
bolded text in line
five but also don't do the changes in
line eight the the striketh through
don't do the strike through and don't
through the bolded text in line 10 is
that correct I I think what we're
suggesting is if you accept all of the
changes then it's going to lead to a
higher uh Staffing at the Pu if you uh
if you take out the changes in section
two then you have to take out the Bold
in section
one I think I think that I I think that
Department seeing that you you have
another
one okay representative McGee I can't
think that best okay um So based on what
you were saying it sounds almost as
though you uh are lamenting the fact
that you're not a party in the
proceedings because you you said we we
are not able to
uh you know uh uh we're not a party so
we can't secure the evidence uh in in
the adjudicative proceeding but isn't
that a clear distinction in the role of
the Public Utilities Commission which is
that you're supposed to be adjudicating
based on the evidence presented to you
and not necessarily generating evidence
to sway a case one way or the other uh
you're absolutely correct and I we're
definitely not lamenting the part that
we are not a party at this point what
I'm saying is is if you take out if you
take out two which is how this was set
up that the uh state would participate
by the department of energy and uh help
with uh you know as their role as also
the state's policy driver and the
regulator and the enforcer if you take
that out of the situation then you have
to also understand we are not a party
and we can't do those things in that
situation so currently now there's no
issue because there you have the
department of energy and you have the
you have the utility and then we're the
Arbiter but if there's no Department of
energy and you just have the regulated
utility I just I it needs to be clear um
to everybody then there there is no
there is no other party if this
legislation was just to go into effect
today as is there are proceedings at the
discretion of the Department of energy
where there would be nobody on the other
side of the table and in those
situations we currently with the
legislation that we have cannot uh
participate the way
um the department of energy
would yes so the please speak yeah let
chairman goldner speak and then you can
follow up thank you um I was just going
to add to that that um we our role is
really as rate maker adjudication is a
part of our role but really our role is
ratemaking and so that's what we're
trying to do is we're trying to balance
the interest of the customer and the
regulated utility to make those rates
and adjudication is a piece of that but
not everything that we do I just wanted
to add that component thank you okay now
followup please thank you so much so uh
I'm I'm hearing you again describe a
process where there isn't
anybody um that will be representing or
advocating for the rate payer if the doe
is not involved but we have a consumer
Advocate who actually does play that
role often and well I think so I guess
the question is there there are still
other participants in the proceedings
right that can provide information uh on
behalf of the rap pair there there are
there interveners participate at times
the OCA also has a small operation and
doesn't uh can't always participate in
the docket the OCA participates when the
OCA can and I'll add to that that the
OCA only represents the residential
rapair class and not the uh not the
commercial and Industrial
classes representative bernardy has a
question thank you Mr chair so I guess I
am uh in perplexed by your comment that
if uh section two is not adopted that
the line five is necessary because
if uh it is there you believe the
department of energy is going to be
disingenuous in their participation I I
I I I have to challenge that why are you
saying that that would be the case I I
appreciate the question and I would just
say I think
you the your question might have said
that we uh would want the line five um I
don't don't know it to be the case I
know from conversations that that was a
conversation and there wasn't you know
and and and that was that was the
statement that that the conversation we
had beforehand was you know so if you
take out two but you leave line five
does that mean that you could come you
you're a mandatory party you could come
and do nothing and I mean that's what it
says I I don't have um
I don't have reason to believe that I
don't have reason to think that the
department of energy has done anything
in our dockets other than
represent
uh the interest of the state in the
policymaking um you know I think that
the department of energy works really
hard at their jobs so um and if I shared
a disregard for that I apologize because
I really do think the department of
energy works really hard at their jobs
may I add to representative ber bernardy
that that um there are different ways to
skin this cat um the department has
recommended one way and we're trying to
be responsive to the proposal that the
department put forward um the resources
could be in the Attorney General's
office uh the resources could be in the
Pu uh perhaps the doe is asking for
additional resources I don't um there's
different ways to solve the problem so
we're just trying to be responsive to
this Committee in terms of the
department put forward a proposal here's
what what we the PC believe we would
need to do to execute that proposal um
but there are many different ways to
problem follow up yes so
uh then I just want to get this clear
if do you believe there are additional
resources necessary
if section two is struck
line five has maintained does the doe or
need more resources in order to be
responsive to the
pu's uh actions I I won't uh I won't
answer a question on behalf of the due
but what I can say is that given the um
given I won't repeat back what you just
said but given that description
additional resources would be required
somewhere the Attorney General's office
the puc somewhere because there would be
no no counterparty to the
Monopoly in those
instances I
think go ahead I I think if section two
is struck there is
I'm sorry Mr bernardy please
representative Bernardi please uh please
again one more time I I I might have
misunderstood your question so I believe
if section two is
struck then the doe is going to be there
100% of the time and uh and line if line
five is
maintained uh then the only issue it
would be if their participation is
disingenuous but the real question is if
line five is maintained section two is
struck do you see a need for additional
resources from someplace because they're
not going to be there when needed yes
and and where what so the so the the
resources could be in different places
if the department is not participating
they've I the way I understood your
question was in in line five if it says
as determined by the department so the
department determines that they're not
uh they um they're not going to
participate in that case they're they're
they're they're not providing anything
on the record then the commission will
likely have questions that um that would
not be uh that where we we would need a
counterbalance so maybe the Attorney
General's office could help us maybe uh
but we can't we don't have access to
Discovery um and so we we need to get
the information
somehow attorney Fuller would you have
any further
comment yeah I just would say we don't
know um I think much to chair goldner's
uh analysis it if if the department CA
if their a mandatory party and came and
said you know we we chose to um to have
limited uh review of this matter because
on our analysis it looked fine and that
was the only thing they put before us
it's possible that we would uh need to
have additional resources to assess the
pleadings um I but again if if it's you
know if the just the change to line five
is simply
semantics for it's what for what the
department says they think they need to
be independent they want this in there
then it's not going to change anything
then it might not I think to answer
question if you took out two um would
would the Pu need additional resources
um we're not quite
sure followup one one further followup
so
so in in that in that case if the doe
comes to the table as now would be
required section two is removed and said
we reviewed this and we only have
concerns about this one issue do you not
have the capability of asking the doe
what about X Y and Z and get a response
from
them I mean we
can I mean they could come to the table
with nothing it's not like we have
concerns about this one issue but they
could come to the table with nothing and
if they don't I mean I think we're
getting out of
the going back to what um
attorney shulock and Deputy Commissioner
ens were talking about and we would
disagree we don't tell the department of
energy how to allocate their resources
when we're on the bench so so can we ask
questions yes but if we don't know if we
don't have any information before us to
base the question on it becomes a very
difficult
situation thank
you okay additional questions
representative rolds
thank you Mr chairman um I guess I'm
also skeptical of your seems like you're
contending that in some cases if the
department of energy declines to get
involved and there is a
significant can I interrupt to you you
said you were skeptical which indicates
you may be interested in a debate
remember we're here to ask questions
okay yeah my
um have there been instances then where
I mean the let's say we mentioned the
the consumer Advocate participates on
behalf of consumers but you mentioned
commissioner goldner uh Industrial and
Commercial there's no you know advocate
for them but ratemaking for those class
of customers involves significant
amounts of
money are you say are you telling us
that there have been cases where the Bia
or somehow industry commercial industry
just don't uh get involved they don't uh
become a um what's it called become a an
intervenor they just don't intervene on
behalf of and a case and and you are
left with nothing to counterbalance the
utilities um
proposals does that happen the short
answer is yes um I think that in my
tenure uh on the on the commission so I
came in April of 21 so I think there was
the idea before that I had come under
the old commission that was only for
eight or 10 weeks so I wasn't here for
very long but under the old
commission but in my ten Year's chair
which began in November of 21 um the
commercial and Industrial interests are
not represented very often I would say
the the OCA represents the residential
interests much more frequently than the
commercial commercial interests are
represented today and then in part
that's because it's a state agency
there's a state agency representing the
interest of residential repairs and
there's no state agency representing the
commercial and
Industrial interests and um and so they
uh the commercial industrial interests
generally show up for the really large
cases uh a large rate case for example
you would see commercial and Industrial
interest but for the vast majority of
cases we don't see them
followup well is the reason of course we
don't have a state agency representing
the commercial and Industrial is because
it's presumed that they
are large and have the resources to you
know employ uh someone or some a law
firm perhaps or economic analyst
to represent them in cases where it
matters
um you know allocation of resources is a
determinant in our society of like
so I'm just again um I'm feeling like
you're making a an issue out of
something
then okay all right seeing no further
questions I want to thank the uh
commissioner for coming before us today
okay thank you and now we'll talk to the
man who is responsible for the uh
representing the interests of the
residential rate payers that's Don Cree
of the Office of Consumer Advocate good
morning Mr Greece uh good morning
chairman Vose
um as you just mentioned my name is
Donald Cree I am the consumer Advocate I
represent the interests of residential
rate payers pursuant to RSA
36328 I have to confess to you that I
have never approached this witness table
to talk about a bill with more
reluctance uh I'm very very very
concerned about what I have heard today
my job as the state's consumer Advocate
is to uh uh win favor with the Public
Utilities Commission on behalf of the
constituency that I represent and my
testimony today is in support
of the bill that is before you House
Bill 266 and again I state that uh very
reluctantly and I would also like you to
know that I have not in any way
coordinated my testimony with that of
the Department of energy I listened
carefully to what Deputy Commissioner
Elms and general counsel shulock said
and I have to say that I agree with
every word that they spoke here today uh
from my perspective the bill you are
considering today is uh uh properly
considered or accurately considered as
part of a triumverate of bills that is
pending before the legislature in
addition today to today's Bill there is
House Bill
535 which uh representative Corman was
gracious enough to introduce at my
request that bill which you have already
heard uh addresses many of the same
issues it goes at the issue that this
bill is Raising from a slightly
different perspective uh trying to
adjust or optimize or improve or just
change the pu's enabling statute this
bill representative Harrington's Bill
tries to do some of the same things I
think by adjusting the pu's enabling
statute but the uh the problem is that
utility regulation in New Hampshire is
not working now I mentioned at trium the
third bill is House Bill
610 and you will have to for for me but
everything I do right now and certainly
everything I say today is something I
view through the through the lens of
House Bill 610 which I hope most of you
know or all of you know is a bill that
would abolish my office outright my
testimony here today is that utility
regulation in this state is broken there
are three agencies that do it and the
one they're talking about abolishing is
mine my office the OCA is not the office
that is broken what is broken is the
working relationship between the
department of energy and the Public
Utilities Commission I I would like to
take this opportunity to answer a
question that I thought uh was extremely
perceptive posed by representative
Corman he asked the department to
summarize succinctly what the job of the
department is and what the job of the
puc is I have an answer to that question
the job of the department is to make
energy policy on behalf of the executive
branch of state government to decide
amongst a variety of options what's good
and bad uh so that the state moves
forward on the pressing questions
related to energy and utilities the job
of the Public Utilities Commission and
frankly I disagree with what I heard
chairman goldner say about the role of
the Public Utilities Commission the job
of the Public Utilities Commission is to
act like a court and decide cases to
listen to the evidence presented in
front of it by Advocates including me
including the department of energy and
then to resolve cases not to make energy
policy
so the uh Department said that it was
reluctant to talk about pending cases uh
I'm not reluctant to talk about pending
cases uh there is no statute or legal
principle or ethical obligation that I
have as an attorney attorney that
forbids me from coming here before this
body and talking about cases pending
before the public use uh Public
Utilities Commission the Public
Utilities Commission has a statutory
code of ethics RSA
36312 and among the things that that
statute says is that the commission must
avoid exp parte contact meaning
discussing its cases outside of the Pu
hearing room where everybody has a
notice and opportunity to be heard and
the Pu has an obligation to avoid making
public statements that would tend to
cast doubt upon its impartiality I am
extremely concerned about that I am so
concerned about that that later today I
will be filing a motion to disqualify
the three Commissioners and one of its
hearings examiners based on testimony
that was presented before this very
committee about default Energy Service
uh about two weeks ago while I was on
vacation I watched the recording of that
hearing and I was floored the Pu should
not be here discussing pending cases at
that time they came in front of you and
talked about I believe the count is four
open cases that are presently pending
before the Public Utilities Commission
that is not the way RSA
36312 or the administrative procedure
act or the pu's enabling statutes are
supposed to work as far as pending
dockets are are concerned I would urge
all of you to take a look at the pending
eversource rate case that is docket
number de
2470 and I'm about to tell you something
about that case it is a pending case and
I'm going to talk about it because again
no principle forbids me from talking
about it here those principles those
legal obligations may call on others to
stand up and walk out of the room right
now whether they do that or not is
entirely up to
them that case is turning into a fiasco
and the reason it is turning into a
fiasco is that there is a massive
squabble that has been going on between
the department of energy and the Public
Utilities Commission most recently the
Public Utilities Commission entered an
order complaining about why the
department and the other parties and the
utility hadn't entered into a settlement
agreement by the deadline for such an
agreement here's the reason the Pu has
made it impossible impossible for
parties like me to enter into settlement
agreements why is that because the Pu
shows no difference and no respect for
settlement agreements that parties like
us the department of energy and
utilities sign well when there's no
difference and no respect there's no
longer any incentive to settle and so we
are on the brink of presenting the first
fully contested rid case to uh to the
Public Utilities Commission really in
the years that I've been doing this and
the Pu has allocated 5 days of hearing
time that's going to take 20 days of
hearing time and it is a mess it's a
mess there are other cases like that I
could talk about there are default
Energy Service cases there are two
Liberty Utilities rate cases there's the
NIT metering dogget there's Energy
Efficiency any number of these things uh
not too long ago The Joint Committee on
legislative
uh or administrative
rules uh approved new procedural rules
for the Pu and there was a lot of
concern uh at the Jal car about the
relationship between the Pu and the
department of energy so much so that
representative Lynn who I think all of
you know he's the former Chief Justice
of this state and he knows a lot about
the law and about how state government
is supposed to work and he was concerned
about what he characterized as
squabbling between two executive branch
agencies I share that concern and I
think all of you should share that
concern as
well uh I was uh a bit astonished
frankly to hear the Pu suggest to you
that it should no longer be
administratively attached to the
Department of energy pursuant to RSC 21
G10 we and the Pu are both
administratively attached to the
Department of energy under that state
statute what does that mean it means
simply that we use their business office
to keep our finances and our back office
functions straight it is terribly
compelling that these three agencies be
administratively attached that way why
two reasons one the the department of
energy has an excellent business office
run by Lenny Rdio who is an extremely
competent financial analyst who used to
work for the Department of
administrative Services I can't imagine
not continuing to work with Mr Rdio I'm
absolutely floored that the Pu thinks
that it doesn't need him anymore there's
an even better practical reason why
these three agencies should remain
administratively attached we are all
funded the same way VIA utility
assessment the department sends out
bills to the state's utilities that
ultimately pay for our three agencies
that is the efficient approp rate and
reasonable way to do this if the Pu
peels itself off and becomes
administratively attached to something
else we will lose that efficiency that
will exert upward budgetary pressure on
my office and the department of energy
and make all of this stuff work even
less well than it is already working
this is costing
money the thing that I care about it
most as the state's rate payer Advocate
as the state's advocate for residential
rate payers and by the way as to the
question about the scope of our work my
counterpart in main the public Advocate
her job is to represent all rate payers
if the problem is that commercial and
Industrial customers are going
unrepresented well then you can Tinker
with or improve the enabling statute of
my office and tell me and my staff that
we should represent all rate payers most
of the time there isn't any conflict but
my point here is that this is costing
all rate payers money efforts are being
duplicated efforts are being wasted it's
costing rate payers money Governor aot
has convened a commission on
governmental efficiency this is a
textbook example of a subject that that
body should take up and it should also
be very troubling and worrisome to all
of you because again utility regulation
in this state is not working please help
say thank you for your compelling
testimony we have questions I see from a
variety of people representative Summers
has the first one thank you Mr chairman
and thank you Mr Cree for taking my
question um as co-sponsor this bill I
was looking at as fact is what you
pointed out basically taking a stab at
trying to improve efficiency um is there
anything you see that's lacking within
this bill or would it need another do
you have another bill or um things we
can add or changes we can make to to
resolve the
inefficiency I I apologize
representative summar because this
answer is going to sound a little glib
but I think you should look with favor
on House Bill 535 because again IT
addresses or attempts to address some of
the same problems and and to be candid I
I think this is a fruitful subject for
some sort of work session I was in
Earnest when I said the commission on
governmental efficiency should look at
this I gave my best shot at figuring out
how I thought we could address some of
these issues that is what you see in
House Bill uh 535 and uh representative
Harrington has given his best shot at
this in collaboration with the
Department of energy I think those bills
can be combined and I think this problem
can be uh grappled with successfully um
in a way I mean you
know when the department of energy was
created four years ago via the Budget
Trailer bill it was understood quite
explicitly at the time that it wasn't
perfect right it was going to be
iterative we put the department of
energy into place we changed the role of
the Pu and said all right we're going to
have to try to figure out how to get
this right here's our first attempt
we've had four years of experience it
isn't working right it needs to be
fixed hope that was helpful
representative parall has a question
thank you chair Rose and thank you for
uh preparing before us
toight you were speaking about how these
two departments are administratively
attached uh one being serving more the
role of a judicial branch and the others
being serving more of an executive
branch um do you see this bill before us
as blurring the lines
between uh those two areas being either
judicial or executive well uh I I guess
I'm sort of a victim of my law school
training and so I I feel like I need to
clarify which is the Public Utilities
Commission is not part of the judicial
branch it is part of the executive
branch as is the Department of energy as
technically I am so we're all working
essentially under the egis of Governor
aot trying to do the jobs that you the
legislature have assigned to us and the
job that you assigned to the Pu in my
opinion is to adjudicate things under
the pu's enabling statute and the
administrative procedure act now now you
know there are lots of other
conversations to be had some of them are
playing out in Washington about the role
of administrative agencies but as in the
federal government here we're talking
about EX executive branch
agencies no followup uh representative
Kaplan has a question thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr cre for coming in this
is a a further clarification question uh
just for my benefit uh it sounds like
there's a sort of a turf war going on
and uh due to the restructuring you know
as you as you mentioned being worked out
in real time so to speak um and you
mentioned squabbling between the the two
U agencies that the um puc and and the
department how how does this bill
address the squabbling specifically and
you know specifically the lines about uh
as determined by the department in line
five and uh section two I mean could you
be more specific and and and and just
detail for me how this bill resolves the
issues that you
see well in my humble opinion I I I also
think you as I said before to take a
serious look at House Bill 535 because
it clarifies what the job of the p is as
I read House Bill 266 which I had no
role in drafting I think what it does is
it
clarifies what the department of energy
is allowed to do and what the Pu can
tell it to do the department of energy
shouldn't report to the Pu in any way
and I think fundamentally that's what
this build tries to get at and I think
it's
appropriate
followup microphone sorry uh followup
question is H how would you address the
issue then of uh the lack of ability on
the part of the Pu to require evidence
to to come before them well the puc is
an adjudicative body and I I uh so I've
been involved in utility regulation
since
1999 when I came to New Hampshire as a
fledgling staff attorney at the Public
Utilities Commission but before that I
spent 5 years working for two State
Supreme Courts and one federal district
court and I can tell you especially
having worked at a federal trial court
that judges complain all the time about
being stuck with the record and the
advocacy that gets presented to the
court by parties that is a frustration
of dis iders who are because of the EXP
parte rules walled off from freewheeling
contact uh and just have to depend on
The Advocates to do a good job but pu
Commissioners like judges can ask
questions at hearing they can manage
their cases they can make clear to the
parties what the court needs in order to
uh decide the cases properly my job is
to go in front of the Pu and win that's
what I want to do on behalf of the cons
constituency I represent so if I go in
front of the Pu and chairman goldner uh
or the other Commissioners tell me what
they think they need me to produce by
way of evidence so that I can win am I
going to listen to them and meet their
me representative Thomas has a question
uh Wendy Thomas thank you uh Mr chair um
other states have pu's and Departments
of energy and they seem to play nice
with each other what are they doing that
we're not doing is go ahead uh my
favorite example is actually uh and I
say this with some reluctance Vermont uh
and it's because I worked briefly at the
Vermont pu so I've had a front row seat
to watch how this works Vermont has a
Department of Public Service and a
Public Utility Commission uh and I I
think the difference between Vermont and
New Hampshire is that Vermont's been
doing it for longer the Department of
Public Service in Vermont was created
many many decades ago and they've had a
longer time to kind of work out the
respective relationships between the two
organizations and you know there are
tensions that are similar are the ones
we're talking about here that arise over
there but it's very clear in Vermont
that the Pu is the adjudicator and the
Department of Public Service is the
policy shop that I think is what the
legisl intended our department of energy
to be when it created the department in
uh in 20 uh 21 you know I would ask you
to go back and look at the testimony the
Pu offered to you about the default
Energy Service Bill and you know I heard
Mr spidell talk to you all about this
body of evidence that the Pu had
developed internally that it hasn't
revealed to anybody that is exactly what
is not supposed to be
happening followup followup so is it
fair to um for you to characterize this
as Growing
Pains uh that would be the sort of
modest and restrained
characterization my that my mother would
probably urge upon me thank
you additional
questions representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr Cree for taking
my question so to get back to the bill
and the changes in the bill it appears
that the department of energy is asking
for some clarifications and statutory
language that make it clear uh that
they're in charge of um
of which cases they're working in front
you know that they have some latitude
right they're not being required to be
involved in every case in cases where it
might not be appropriate um so do you
see you mentioned both both bills I went
and looked back at 535 and I see what
you're saying about that bill because
that bill it sounds to me like would
help with the fact that some cases are
being slow walked or slow rolled over
time where they could be settled and
they're not being so it seems like this
bill is more asking us to change
language so that there's a clarification
between the two departments of how their
roles are going to operate is that an
accurate assessment yes I would say so
and do you think that the changes that
are bolded in this uh in all the
sections that we've discussed and the
repeal um section
under on line 26 uh section five that
all of that is is um appropriate because
you said you didn't have any hand in
this bill but you've read it yes I I
support the bill and I think all of the
changes contained in the bill would be
appropriate and constructive thank
you so I heard you say a little a few
minutes ago that the puc has developed a
body of
evidence on its own that it hasn't
revealed what is that in regard to uh I
simply I was on vacation when you heard
the default Energy Service bill which I
believe is House Bill 760 and when I
came home from vacation I watched uh
hearings EX examiner spidell's testimony
and what he was talking to you about and
you all were here I was not but what he
was talking to you about was analysis
that the Pu had conducted internally
that demonstrated that when you rely
either significantly or exclusively on
the iso New England spot Market uh for
default Energy Service Supply uh there
will be I think he said in 99 out of 100
cases an over
recovery so that there wouldn't be a
default Energy Service shortfall I don't
I would love to see where they get that
from but they have not revealed it and
uh I'm just relying on what I heard Mr
spidel say to
you so as far as you know that's not
evidence that's been submitted to them
by someone else uh I believe he said it
was evidence that they had developed
internally meaning potentially I I know
that pu hires outside Consultants from
time to time that work with them so uh
so so and again this is exactly the kind
of thing that creating the department of
energy was supposed to prevent from
happening right like basically the
evidence that the Pu considers is
supposed to be vetted at contested
hearings so that people have
opportunities to cross examine the
witnesses and develop uh a full and fair
body of evidence in the case of default
Energy Service the Pu has settled upon a
policy approach there are lots of
different ways of doing default service
the puc favors a particular method they
would like to rely exclusively on the
spot market and they would like to take
any shortfalls any under recoveries or
over recoveries and socialize those
responsibilities among all customers
regardless of what class they're in or
whether they're relying on default
service now I don't agree with any of
that but those are policy choices and I
on behalf of the constituency I
represent have a right under the
administrative procedure Act and the
pu's enabling statute to subject that
evidence to skeptical scrutiny and
that's exactly what's not
happening thank you for clarifying that
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and uh Mr GRE
thank you again uh I I just playing the
devil's advocate here I believe what
you're saying is that the Pu is is is uh
counting on its internal resources
inappropriately but what this pu told us
in relation to this bill is that they
would be forced to do that even more
because they won't have the resources of
the state at their disposal so would
that be an unintended consequence I do
not think so I with all respect to my
friends at the p and again you know I I
gained nothing particularly this week by
coming before you and saying saying
things that will antagonize the Pu I I
know almost everybody who works at the
puc I know they're all good
well-intentioned people who come to work
every day hoping to do the right thing
for the uh cons for the state and all of
its people uh but they have attorneys
they have experts they have at least as
many resources as a court would have if
you presented all these cases to uh say
the superior court or the federal
district court I'm confident in their
ability to decide cases based on the
evidence that is presented to them by
Advocates but instead what you have is
the Pu because again it's pursuing
policy uh migrating towards what I would
call an inquisitorial model where they
basically come in and they've already
decided what they want to do and they
haul people before them and ask them
questions that are designed to build the
record to get to the answer that they
want that is a legitimate way of doing
things it happens not to be the way way
you have told them you want the Pu to do
things representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr Cree for taking
my
question if the Pu needs the information
adjudication
and trying to figure out the best way to
say this shouldn't the
doe be part of every case I mean that's
where information comes from um so I
mean the bill would would um would say
that the doe does not have to be part of
every case I I don't think it's
appropriate to compel the department of
energy to appear in every case in every
case that is presented to a tribunal
somebody has the burden of proof meaning
if they want X to happen they have to
demonstrate by a preponderance of the
evidence and based on the law that that
outcome is appropriate so if that party
doesn't come before the puc and meet its
burden of proof then the Pu is obliged
to say
no that's how this should work again I'm
I'm a victim of my legal training that's
what I learned in law
school representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you again Mr C quick question for you
earlier that you probably heard I think
you were sitting here when I asked the
Pu earlier about if we pass this bill if
it would slow down the process the
dockets even making it more defined of
the responsibilities of doe and pu and
he and they stated that it would slow
down the process of docket fixture do
you agree with that statement and um
what's your opinion of that well I guess
I have two answers I mean one the Pu
controls the pace of its docket process
to some degree my answer is a
recapitulation of the answer I just gave
representative Corman which is you know
the Pu can efficiently decide cases
based on who has the burden of proof and
whether that burden has been met so I
don't accept the premise that
automatically moving forward with a bill
like this or moving forward with House
Bill 535 would slow down the process but
how efficiently this works is really the
uh that that's a decision for the pu to
make when I was General Counsel of the
Pu what I said to my colleagues in the
agency including the Commissioners all
the time is we are a decision Factory
our product is our def our decisions our
job is to get it to the people who need
it as quickly efficiently and
expeditiously as possible so that people
can either live with our decision or
file an appeal to challenge our decision
I still think that's the way the Pu
should conceive of its Mission not as an
avatar of enlightened energy
policy that's the Department's job to be
the Avatar of enlightened energy policy
representative bernardy has a
question thank you Mr chair so uh
recapitulate what I think you're you're
saying is is uh if a case is in front of
the Pu uh and they need additional
evidence from those that are there
making their case they can ask for that
and if they don't get it then they make
the decision based on the information
they've received and chips fall where
they may is that true that is a correct
you okay see no further questions I want
to thank you for your testimony and
since I have no more pink cards we will
close the public hearing on House Bill
and move quickly to a public hearing on
house resolution 15 and I will call on
the prime sponsor of that resolution
representative Michael Harrington to
good morning again uh hopefully this
bill will be a little less controversial
than the last one um what this bill does
is it it's a it's a house resolution
to it resolved that the general court
urges our elected members of the United
States Congress to take whatever actions
are possible to change FK policy so only
costs associated with new upgraded
electrical transmission projects that
are found to be just and reasonable can
be collect collected from The Raid
payers the easiest way to explain this
is with an example if a a utility
electric water with this case would be
electric utility uh goes out and works
on a distribution project and a
substation and they spend let's say $4
million on that they have to file that
with the Pu and they have the burden of
proof to show that the cost are just in
reasonable imprudent and therefore they
that's how they get their compensation
if F the costs are not found just
reasonable then they don't get paid for
that portion of their project simple as
that uh for example when I was a
commissioner uh back when the utilities
own generation there was a case at one
of the generation facilities where there
was a water hammer problem W go into the
details about water hammer but it causes
a lot of damage in steam power plants
and they presented that and they wanted
to collect the money to repair it as
well as for buying replacement power I
asked one question I said water hammers
are caus you the by operator error or by
equipment failure which was this they
didn't have the answer to the best of my
knowledge they never responded and they
never collected that money because
apparently it must have been uh operator
error so that's the way it works when
it's a distribution or substation that's
controlled under the state rules now
flash ahead they're doing a $400 million
project on a transmission line and they
file all their costs with FK and FK
looks at it and says and you got to
remember these filings when they were
paper would be like measured in feet
okay that's how how W they are FK just
takes the big pile and sticks them over
here and goes we presume everything is
prudent it's called presumption of
prudency it was introduced some Years
Ago by the furk and recently talked to a
FK former FK commissioner who said it
was the worst decision he ever made when
he did that but that presumption of
prudency means unless someone comes down
in in shows this particular cost is not
just and reasonable they automatically
get put it in the rates there's no check
on it and let's face it there isn't
anybody out there there's no
organization or agency whose task with
saying I'm going to go through 5,000
10,000 pages of submitt by a
transmission utility and see if
everything on there is just and
reasonable they don't have the power to
you know have access to their records to
question people and this isn't the
entity FK could do that if they chose to
but they chose not to so this just
simply says we're urging our
Congressional representatives to do
something about that and to make FK do
their job just like is done by the Pu
and I think every state in the country
where you have to show the cost adjust
and reasonable before you get or you
don't get paid not that we presume
everything is dust and reasonable and
let's proven otherwise and I'll take any
questions questions for representative
Harrington representative McGee
jumped in front of you uh thank you
representative Harrington for taking my
question you know I think this is
probably a a good thing to do um but I
wondered whether you might consider
adding a findings
section up front so that maybe our
Congressional folks would understand uh
the reasoning for it because they may
not understand how or why they should
get involved to try and Advocate if they
don't have maybe a little of what you
gave us and terms of a synopsis around
make this easy I have no problem with
that if you especially if you want to
write it up thanks so much appreciate
that just what I
need okay so representative McGee
volunteers to write findings
representative Thomas uh Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um just if this is
going to go to Congress on line two you
use the word Justified and reasonable
that goes to line three and on lines 11
and 12 you is just and reasonable they
should be similar yeah they should be
just and reasonable thanks for catching
that and one of the thing I should
mention also is that this uh effort is
not uh limited to just New Hampshire
there's efforts by other states
especially in New England uh we just had
the consumer Advocate leave the consumer
Advocate groups of New England have been
looking at this as well uh and so we're
trying to get uh you know a bigger push
because it's it's nothing radical it's
just simply says that you have to have
to hold the same standard to repair or
build a transmission line that you do
when you repair or build a distribution
system that that's it's not crazy and
there is a uh a lot of projects it's
called asset conditioning that's the
that's the jingle term for upgrading
these transmission lines a lot of it's
replacing old wooden poles with steel
poles I'm not saying these aren't
necessary aren't needed but the burden
of showing just and reasonable should be
on the transmission company and not
assume that everything is prudent so
like I said other states are looking at
this as well and you have to understand
if they spend $500 million in a project
in Conneticut 10% of that charge
basically goes to New Hampshire rid
payers so it's not just the pro
transmission projects built in New
Hampshire it's any place in New England
so representative parel has a question
thank you chair and thank you for
interesting this bill um I don't know if
it's uh I can ask this question right
now but have you taken any consideration
about the body on the other side of the
wall and getting this I think it's great
I I would love to see get past them and
get to the governor's desk I figured it
one step at a time getting through this
committee and then getting through the
house and then I'll deal with the Senate
that's thank
you representative
Reynolds thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh representative Harrington for for
taking the lead on this you alluded to
it in your your last um reply but I was
going to ask kind of specifically um has
there been you know any resolutions or
advocacy on by bodies like uh naruk the
the National Association of regulatory
Commissioners or the New England you
know on this topic
this are we yeah I don't know about
don't don't know necessarily National I
know I've Ted with the people at the
department of energy and it is a big
issue I've talked to Nesco people I me
New England New England states committee
on electricity I guess so that's the
that's the organization that was formed
some years ago to give the states a
small um independent agency to represent
them at the uh Nee poool and ISO New
England meetings they're they've brought
this issue up they've concerned with the
and I probably got the term wrong but
it's the equivalent of the New England
um
group or organization of consumer
Advocates has also had meetings on this
and they've been looking at it as well
my Dawn could probably give you more
information on that okay thank
you so you mentioned in your
introduction
that Burke currently has a
prudency um assumption that they make
about presumption of prudency that's
what it's called presumption of prudency
but the question I have is this
resolution never mentions that
um Assumption of
prudency so can we assume that the
Congress people who get this resolution
will understand that that's what this is
all about well maybe that's something
that would be a a change that would
improve it yeah I mean they probably
they probably won't know that so I
should say that you know FK operates
under presumption in prudency which
means that the transmission costs are
considered just unreasonable unless
proven otherwise we could there's going
to be an amendment anyways because of
what representative Thomas caught so we
certainly change that and put some more
information and we have representative
McGee fine words coming as well so okay
further
questions representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Harrington this is
really
interesting I don't know what the
workload of FK is like but it seems like
this would then generate additional work
for them to actually verify the just and
reasonable
costs um do you have any idea is is FK
already overburdened and would this
actually increase any
backlog I assume it would create more
work for f obviously if they unless
they're just going to rub a stamp it a
different way that uh they would have to
have some type of hearing on this or
some type of adjudicative process it
will create it definitely will create
more cost but remember when we're not
talking Mill millions of dollars here
we're talking hundreds of billions of
dollars Nationwide on these transmission
projects and it's not limited to New
England it's over the whole country
we're also talking about you know the
need to upgrade transmission because of
data centers because of more distributed
generation because of intermittent uh
resources and battery storage all those
are looking at new transmission with
we're talking it maybe even in the
trillions of dollars it's so much so I
think that spending something just like
like we do in new New Hampshire we could
turn around and take the same policy
here and just tell the utilities you
know whatever you think is just in
reasonable we'll put into rates for you
but we don't do that this is on a larger
scale but I think it's even more
important been done you know as a friend
of mine former commissioner from Rhode
Island says that the uh transmission
companies are the largest unregulated
Monopoly in the United States because of
goes thank you no further questions and
having no additional pink cards uh we
will close the public hearing on house
or resolution
15 one quick clarification on that this
is a house resolution which means it
goes no further than the house there is
another kind of resolution called an HCR
which stands for house continuing
resolution or concurrent resolution and
that does go to the Senate this one
however would not go to the
Senate okay so with that we'll now turn
to our
next uh public hearing which is on House
Bill 599 so I will open a public hearing
on House Bill 599 establishing a
committee to examine weatherization
initiatives for homes in New Hampshire I
will call on representative Heath Howard
legislation good morning representative
tardiness you were here earlier so I I
knew you were just out in the
hall well thank you I appreciate it uh
am I am I all set to get started here
all right wonderful
uh hello everyone my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington in
straford District 4 uh thank you
honorable Mr chair and committee members
for being here
today I want you all to imagine a family
shivering through another harsh winter
despite working
tirelessly uh they have to face
impossible choices heating their homes
buying groceries or paying for medical
bills this isn't just a story this is
the reality for thousands of granite
Staters and today I encourage you to
support forming AUD study committee to
look at the weatherization of homes in
our state New Hampshire Winters are cold
and you can see it in our energy bills
with 60% of our homes being built before
1980 many lack modern Energy Efficiency
upgrades the result families spend up to
30% more on their income on heating far
above the national average
weatherization can cut these costs by
25% saving households hundreds
annually residential energy use accounts
for 20% of our state's carbon emissions
and weatherization could reduce our our
state footprint by decreasing
demand imagine the impact if just half
of our homes were weatherized we'd cut
emissions equivalent to taking 50,000
cars off the road and this committee
would help us align with New Hampshire's
climate action plan ensuring that we
meet our 2030 sustainability goals cold
homes aren't just uncomfortable they're
also dangerous poor insulation leads to
dampness mold and respiratory illnesses
for our elderly risks like hypothermia
Skyrocket a study in Manchester found
weatherized homes had 30% fewer en uh
emergency room
visits uh and by addressing these
hazards we could protect our most
vulnerable and reduce public healthc
care
burdens low-income and Rural households
suffer the most because they often live
in older homes lack up fun funds for
upgrades and face energy insecurity a
committee will ensure targeted Solutions
like expanding the NH weatherization
assistance program to help bridge this
Gap some may argue why a new committee
existing efforts are commendable but
they're fragmented a centralized body
will unify stakeholders help leverage
federal funds and prioritize data div
strategies um while also the fact that
this would help uh us put a plan in
place so that every dollar that we spend
would return $2.50 in societal benefits
the payoffs are clear and we should be a
state that turns challenges into
opportunities let's form a study
committee to strategize and act for the
families struggling for our environment
and for New Hampshire's Legacy let's
build a future where no one must choose
between warmth and survival thank
you thank you for introducing this
legislation questions for representative
Howard representative Kaplan thank you
Mr chairman and thank you m
representative Howard for bringing this
fine bill I I support it wholeheartedly
um I you know agree with your assessment
that it would uh help with solving our
carbon footprint and it's an imperative
to make quality of life better for our
residents um would you also agree that
given the housing shortage and
especially the the affordability crisis
in our housing stock that this would be
a a key element in solving the housing
crisis in our state yeah I I I do think
that it would uh I think that in terms
of uh the solutions for our our housing
strategy that we need to put forward we
need to make sure that we aren't just
building as many homes as possible but
we have to build quality homes that
Hampshire uh I have a question for you
so then in Hampshire Department of energ
manages several weatherization programs
the New Hampshire saves program which is
administ and administered by the state's
utilities has an extensive
weatherization program why do you think
we need to study weatherization more
than what these entities already know
about weatherization and what they
already do about it uh well thank you
for the question Mr and part of it is
like I said it comes down to creating a
centralized uh voice to actually be able
to combine a lot of these pre-existing
efforts we know uh that there are a lot
of these programs but it's making sure
that we can come together and actually
have a place where people can look at
one location rather than trying to
search through many different uh piles
of loc uh piles of information to find
what they
need okay additional questions
representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman you actually uh
touched on what I was going to ask which
is would it
be effective to just put more money into
NH saves so that NH saves could serve
more people I mean that's a
well-known
program and seems like the the central
place that people would go
anyway yeah I mean that that is a
possibility I mean I I do think that
study additional questions
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um and thank you for being here uh
representative Howard uh do you envision
this committee also looking at the New
Hampshire energy codes as part of this
initiative I could uh very easily see
representative
Kaplan thank you Mr Vice chair uh
followup question for you representative
Howard um we've heard New Hampshire
saves is a fine organization they do
great work in the state do they have a a
knowledge or is it part of their mission
to to assess the the the the state of
our housing stock across the entire
state do they do they look at the
housing stock themselves and say oh
here's where we we can use uh you know
some huge weatherization projects in
Nashville or manest princi or do they
wait for people to come to
them I'm not 100% certain on that that
might be a better question for somebody
else additional questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative uh Howard for being
here today um I'm I'm really interested
in this because I uh was on the easy
board for a while while and I heard from
uh Matt cisa who's with GDs and recently
about this bill um he knew it was coming
to the committee and he gave me he
reached out to me because he mentioned
that uh there is still uh a stakeholder
group of small
weatherization providers uh and other
stakeholders trying to do that very work
that you're talking about trying to
figure out how do we make New
Hampshire's housing stock
more um efficient and uh you know
basically lowering the de on the the
demand side for um external fossil fuels
being imported into the state so I was
just wondering whether in anyone had
reached out to you in terms of um
participation on any type of committee
or
commission uh from the state because
there are people that are you know they
want to do that work but there isn't
really uh any state initiative that's
promoting it at this point which I'm
assuming you're going to want to have a
report come out of this commission right
for what we should do and why we should
do it is that right yeah I I I do want a
report to come out of this if possible
uh but I have not been contacted by
anybody from the state specifically I
have had a few other individuals reach
out uh saying that they would be very
interested in coming to uh the study
representative Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question just uh an
idea instead of a committee uh at this
bill has would it not be perhaps as um
effective to perhaps uh just turn this
into a request to the Department of
energy to perform a report and a study
involving the subject I think they have
a lot of data on their hands as it is
but would that not be uh perhaps more
effective I mean I think that that would
be uh a a fine way of doing it I I mean
but as you know uh being legislators
here uh having uh a little bit more of
an opportunity to have in-depth uh
knowledge and a chance to participate in
good okay seeing no further questions
oops there is one representative F sorry
my habit of holding off to the end thank
you and thank you representative Howards
um the question
is did you reach out to any or did any
reach out to you from the construction
and the
businesses I've I've had a few
individuals reach out um I'm not on %
sure if uh they're business owners or
not I know that one of them has been
very involved with a lot of the energy
code bills uh and has
uh quite a bit of knowledge on that I
think that they are an inspector of some
sort um if that kind of answers your
question follow up thank you chair um my
followup is I might be living in a
bubble do you see a need
to
counter that my bubble
was when I was looking for rehabbing a
place for Pacific issue I was upsal on
all of many um weatherization which I
plan to do myself but everyone I I wish
I had the
numbers volunteered how to do it better
do you see that that lacking that needs
to be looked
into I mean I think that there are a lot
of opportunities for for business people
uh especially if we uh try and uh
provide weatherization options this is
not necessarily trying to impose any new
requirements like certain energy codes
but like you said when we do have the
opportunity for people who are
experienced and have the business
knowledge as to what can be done to
improve uh the weatherization and the
insulation in your home so that you can
save energy I think that there are a lot
of people who are doing a lot of good on
that front but uh it's the fact that
right now uh if we can help provide some
additional opportunities for some of
these business owners to get some of
these resources from the state to figure
out what is the best way to go about uh
providing these so that not only are the
business owners is benefiting but also
the consumer as
well representative scheller has a
question thank you chairman Vos and
thank you representative Howard for
being here uh my my question maybe
touching upon that uh last comment would
this not be better handled by businesses
I mean this is essentially as I
understand it a sales and marketing it's
it's developing a product then sales and
marketing and then taking that product
out to Consumers that actually need the
product if that
exists yeah I I mean that is true but
when we're looking at a number of
different things like reducing our total
energy out usage that's going to when
we're looking at supply and demand and
the total amount that energy costs are
going to be when we have additional
costs to heat people's homes that means
that we're going to have additional
demand meaning that prices are going to
be higher so this is trying to not just
uh make it cheaper for the individual
looking at these weatherization options
so that they lower their own house
energy bills but looking at a state to
try and lower our overall rates as a
you representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um and thank you for taking
my question again um I am a BPI building
analyst um and since taking that course
I cannot drive by a house without
looking at the house at the roof during
the winter time and you can tell where
where the insulation is lacking with
because of ice dams and because of
heating from the house it's it's really
remarkable once you've once you've had
that sort of exposure I would think that
a big part of this would be education
for current not not just business but
current home owners because there are
estimates 30% of our heating bill is
literally going through the roof it's
being wasted in New hampsh sure New
England in general is horrible is there
a question here the the question is do
you also agree that education is a big
part of this yes yes it is and making
sure that all consumers especially
people uh who may not necessarily be as
involved uh with uh looking at their
homes themselves and trying to figure
out when they're going to need some of
these upgrades uh but yes I do think
this okay representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative Howard I just uh I
don't know uh I'm may have had
incomplete notes here but you
referenced turning $1 into
$2.50 or $2 I imagine there's a little
bit that's kind of rough approximation
but you can can you elaborate uh where
that $1 comes from and how it becomes
250 yeah so uh when we're looking at
every dollar that we're spending on
weatherization we can kind of expect
$2.50 back in return uh so that's going
to be $1 on additional insulation or
energy saving
uh services that uh would allow people
to uh save money on their energy bills
uh the $2.50 that benefit comes back
when you're looking at your energy bill
and by every dollar that you spent extra
on those extra insulation products for
instance you would get $2.50 back in
return
followup followup so so then you're
you're saying that uh this is this is
the the homeowner or the business
owner's dollar that this is just educ
educating them how they can turn you
know better invest to get that return on
investment yes correct thank
you okay seeing no further questions
we'll call on Meg Stone from the
Department of energy thank you for
you and this is the final pink card I
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee I'm sorry for the way I sound
today my allergies are um making my life
very difficult recently um so the
department is neutral on House Bill 599
and if the committee decides to move
forward with this uh study committee
prescribed in the bill the department
would be happy to
participate um so five House Bill 599
establishes a committee to St uh with
several duties including identifying the
current state of weatherization programs
analyzing existing programs and
developing a set of proposals to promote
and incentivize weatherization in the
state um so the department man manages
the weatherization assistance program or
U WAP from the US Department of energy
uh we contract with the state's five
Community Action agencies that operate
and deliver weatherization Services um
and this is means tested and limited to
those making 60% or less of State median
income um once eligible and energ
auditor will perform a a home energy
audit and this can include anything from
air sealing to attic insulation um an
insulating crawl spaces or attics um the
Caps are very knowledgeable about the
program the offerings um and other
programs such as New Hampshire saves
that are dedicated to um also stretching
some of our web funding as far as
possible including
supplementing um in order to cover more
eligible more eligible households um for
funding New Hampshire receives about $2
million uh each year subject to
Congressional approval um New Hampshire
also received a one-time appropriation
of18 million for weatherization through
the infrastructure investment and jobs
act um and I think we've received about
50% of that um through the WAP program
and New Hampshire saves supplementing
through the um home energy assistance
program we've served roughly 2500
households um and I will just just note
that uh we' like to identify just two
areas outlined in the duties of the bill
to just bring to your attention um so in
lines 12 and 13 um it states identifying
the current state of weatherization in
our state including the number of homes
that are properly weatherized and those
that are not um the department does not
maintain a database of um homes that
have or have not been weatherized uh nor
do we nor does the tra the department
track um which homeowners May install
and Energy Efficiency measures such as
insulation or updating heating systems
or anything like that um and then in
line 16 or 17 um analyzing existing
weatherization programs and policies at
the local state and federal levels to
identify strengths weaknesses and areas
of improvement um I will just note that
states um are limited in
modifying um or changing the federal WAP
um states are required to compel with
the federal terms and conditions for
their WAP Awards and operating outside
of those requirements could put that
funding at risk so I just wanted to make
sure that I noted that and um I'm happy
to take any
questions well thank you I have a quick
question for you it was mentioned
earlier that education should be a part
of uh this
study can you talk a little bit about
how the department spends the
$400,000 that uh it gets from New
Hampshire saves each year to educate the
public about whether a um as far as the
the specific amount and what we do with
that I'll have to just get back to you
I'll email the committee with with that
information can you tell us in general
terms what the committee's doing uh
spending that money
on I I would I just don't want to
misspeak so I will make sure I get you a
comprehensive answer and send that to
the committee Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question so if this bill
were to pass I'm trying to figure out
the study committee to on the two line
items that you had mentioned um I'm
trying to figure out how they would get
that data uh would this be a voluntary
where people come to your door in your
house to do inspection to find out how
many houses are properly weatherized or
or not how do you think that would work
uh uh in terms of how effective the the
committee could get some of that
data um I'm I'm not sure how how that
could work um other than that being a
voluntary thing that people may just
report on their own um we don't have
somebody that goes out we have a lot of
old homes in the state so we don't have
anyone that goes out to all the homes
asking if they've been weatherized or or
not follow up thanks for the followup so
um it's my understanding though that at
least in terms of eversource um people
can request an energy audit uh on their
house uh free of charge is is that is
that not correct and is it not stated on
their on their bills um yes it's my
understanding that yes they can they can
request a home energy
audit additional questions
representative Harrington has one than
you thank you for taking my question you
you went kind of fast over the uh
numbers there you'd mentioned something
million here and something million there
something cuz you What's the total that
was spending on uh weatherization
programs um through the thank you for
the question through um the federal WAP
funding we receive um about 2 million
each year and that changes a little bit
each year depending on Congressional
approval and then through the
um uh through the infrastructure
investment jobs act uh we've received 18
million um and I believe the state has
received about 50% of that um and I
believe the other 50% has been obligated
we just haven't received it yet and just
a followup followup and what about New
Hampshire saves how much does that spend
a year um I don't I don't have that with
me right now um but I can get you that
information thank
you representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Miss stone
for taking my question um are you aware
of the Statewide weatherization
collaborative that GDs Associates is
running because I I have a note here
that says that
uh that group is meeting monthly to
discuss issues of weatherization in the
state and Workforce and that sort of
thing and they say that they have um
contractors utilities state agencies and
Workforce aligned groups that are
attending those meetings on a regular
basis and bringing in speakers and that
sort of thing in order to discuss all
the issues around
weatherization um I I don't work on
weatherization uh frequently so I I we
do have people who do so I could I I'm I
believe that they're aware of that so I
will just double check with them that
they attend those it's it sounds like
someone's attending so if you could just
let me know what you think of that
because they were very interested in
this bill okay oh I'm sorry what was
that group um they're I guess they're
called the Statewide weatherization
collaborative
okay representative
Thomas uh Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um you mentioned that New
Hampshire has received approximately 9
million of the 18 million um can you
tell me how much of that has been
allocated already to New Hampshire
residents um I believe we have spent uh
50% of that that we that we' have had so
far and um so the way we received it was
uh 15% came in when we applied for it
and then I think it was 35 came in um
after uh after approval and then we've
we've gone through half of that that
we've received so
far
clarification follow follow up so half
you okay seeing no further questions
whoops representative Kaplan last minute
he was chair I um actually have two
questions um first one regarding the 18
million that that we received from the
infrastructure act um do you have any
word or do you expect that we're going
to get the other 50% that's one question
and the second question is uh in terms
of identifying the current state of
weatherization uh including the number
of homes that are properly weatherized
those that are
not um how would the department of
energy facilitate that seeing that you
don't have a database would there be uh
the resources in the department or would
you have to go to the Caps around around
the state to to to determine that those
figures sure um I'm I'm sure that the
Caps do have information on who has
received all of that weatherization the
department is um we are working on
hopefully within the next year having um
a data management system that will be
able to pull reports um similar to that
but as far as homes that you have either
not taken advantage of one of our
programs or something that have done
weatherization on their own um that's
not something we could we would have
access to um and I'm sorry what was your
first question the infrastructure act
are we expecting the other 50% yes so
the other 50% um we I I believe the
department department has to meet
certain benchmarks and I believe that we
um we are at the point where we have met
those benchmarks and we're sending that
back to us doe in order to get the the
obligated okay seeing no further
questions want to thank you for your
testimony here this afternoon or this
morning rather thank you and we will now
close the public hearing on House Bill
599 and I would ask that everyone in the
room who is not a member of the
Republican caucus if you could exit
please because we need to have a
caucus and uh then we will be heading to
lunch after which at 1 pm this afternoon
we will have an executive session on
four separate bills and so we will see
you all then and thank you for being
morning
e
started with our afternoon
activity this afternoon we're going to
exec four
bills House Bill 219 FN
relative to phasing out of the Min minim
minimum electric renewable portfolio
standard HB 567 FN relative to the
elimination of useful thermal energy
from renewable energy
classes HB 696 FN exempting electricity
generators from the utility property tax
and including them under the Statewide
education property tax and relative to
Communication Service tax
revenues and finally HB 764 FN
prohibiting the intentional release of
polluting emissions including cloud
seeding weather modification excessive
electromagnetic radio frequency and
microwave radiation and making penalties
for violation of such
provision now we will not be taking
these in the order that I just read them
because two of these bills have
amendments that are currently still at
OS and will be here shortly so we will
take up those bills when the Amendments
arrive so
first I will open an executive session
on House Bill
587 567 sorry FN and I'll recognize
representative
Harrington I need get one move to itl
the
bill I'm sorry representative could you
repeat
that itl this bill chair recognizes
representative Summers I second that
motion moved and seconded that we adopt
the motion of itl for House Bill 567 FN
representative Harrington you want to
explain your motion yeah the U the I
still think that the U the wood heat
standard is in error and the fact that
um electric rate payers should not be
paying higher rates to subsidize people
burning wood for heat uh but the bill is
probably not going to go anywhere and we
have adjusted some of that in HB 219 and
so I'll just no sense in wasting
everybody's time on this bill let's just
itl it and concentrate on
219 so the clerk just informed me that
he did not get the forms he
needed which I didn't know until just a
second ago so we'll have to delay a vote
on this bill until he gets back with the
proper forms any further discussion on
House Bill 567 representative Thomas um
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um just
piping in to say that I concur with the
discussion representative McGee yeah
I'll just uh pile on I guess um I think
the hearings um were very compelling in
that people from around the state made
time to come in here and speak to us
about uh
how uh the current uh thermal program is
assisting them whether it was uh new
builds or folks who are uh invested like
my town is in uh in boiler
systems um so I just want to say I think
it's a it's a it's great that we're
planning to it because I I think it
would be very disruptive to people who
have already made the efforts to do um
the kind of Investments that we sort of
encourage them to do um and that the it
doesn't disrupt that part of the wreck
program that they are uh reliant on as
many of them testified to make the
plants further discussion representative
Corman if you need me to kill a little
more time before the forms arrive yes I
agree uh we really did hear that a lot
of people are relying on thermal uh
energy and also um newer technology is
efficient so Vice chair Thomas thank you
Mr chairman in an effort to balance the
table I should say I am am also in favor
of
itl Representative rolds well I'll uh
push back then and say uh you know we
heard a lot of compelling testimony here
not just about the substance of the the
actual um functioning of the RPS but the
role that it played in the in the wood
industry and the importance of that so
you know I think that testimony was was
uh overwhelming um but in addition you
know again in my in my past life I work
directly with several school districts
and the county the county in which we
current sit uh that made huge
investments in thermal uh wood pellet or
wood chip heating technology and uh I
think many of us uh
have schools districts schools or uh uh
municipalities that have the same kind
of technology and and pulling the rug
out from under that would just be uh
really a bad idea so I'm in agreement
I'll just say that I think
representative Harrington makes a good
point that paying
for uh thermal energy
under with a search charge on
electricity rates doesn't seem like the
right thing to do so he and I have been
talking
about working over the summer to next
fall uh introduce an LSR to create a
wood heat
standard that would be funded by
revenues from other sources not a tax on
electricity so we will be attempting to
put something like that together and
would certainly welcome suggestions from
anybody uh about how to put that
together representative McGee yeah
thanks um it I that is really the Crux
of the matter that I know representative
Harrington brings up all the time and I
understand why that might be something
to be stuck on but I think there are you
know people are evolving on energy and
there are countries now that look at
BTUs and kilowatt hours they have a way
of converting energy that energy is
energy right and so it may come from
different sources but the I think the
point of the RPS was to help us to uh
transition to cleaner forms of energy
and uh diversify the mix of our energy
and to find ways to lower costs by
leveraging local sustainable sources so
there were a number of objectives that
the RPS was designed to support and
so the idea of parsing all the aspects
of energy as though they aren't all uh
contributing to the costs that we're
paying out as a state is I think in some
ways it's um it's missing the forest for
the trees I guess would be the analogy
that that the idea is that we want
people to be investing in forms of
energy that don't cost us the most and
and make us the most Reliant you know so
um that I think that's how thermal got
added in the first
place okay any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
FN Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative
Harrington yes repres representative Bry
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee yes representative
parall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
yes representative Corman yes
representative rolds yes representative
La relle yes representative Swanson yes
chairman
Bose yes consent 20 Z by a vote of 20 to
zero the committee excuse me 18 18 oh
yeah 18 to Z 20 used to be 20 by the
vote of 18 to zero the committee adopts
the motion of itl on House Bill 567 FN
without objection it'll go on the
consent calendar no objection
hearing no objections it will go on the
consent calendar representative
Harrington will write the committee
report and with that we close the exec
FN next we'll open a exec session on
House Bill
FN and I will move ought to
pass on House Bill 696 FN
and recognize representative schneller
second the motion moved and seconded
that we
judge House Bill 696 to be worthy of an
aut toass vote I will say to begin the
discussion
that this bill results directly from a
three-year study commission a study
commission that was actually
reconstituted three times over three
consecutive years
that studied this issue thoroughly and
while House Bill 696 doesn't capture all
of the concerns that members of the
study commission expressed during our 18
or 16 to 18 hours of meetings uh over
last
fall it does take a giant step forward
in Breaking the litigation Log Jam that
cost both rate payers and taxpayers a
lot of
money that results from the fact that
under the current
system generators who are basically just
manufacturers they manufacture
electricity they are not utilities but
they're being
tax and the assessment for that tax is
done by the Department of Revenue
Administration they come up with an
assessment for a piece of generation
property meanwhile municipalities come
up with an assessment of that same
property for the purposes of Municipal
Taxation and frequently the difference
between those two assessments is huge
and that's what leads to litigation when
a generator sees that the Dr says my
facility is worth X
but the municipality says
my facility is worth
10x then I'm probably going to go to
court to find out what the real assessed
value of my property
is so by exempting generators
manufacturers of electricity from the
utility property
tax and making them subject instead to
the Statewide education property tax
we can
eliminate most if not all of that
litigation there will still be some
litigation probably that survives that
um this transfer or this exemption but
most of it will be taken care of by this
exemption this
exemption preserves pilot agreements for
generators if they currently are in
place it preserves them out to 2032 I
believe it is
and um it also
recognizes that generators are just
manufacturers and tries to treat them uh
as the category of business that they
are so I hope you'll join me in
supporting the aop pass motion on this
discussion representative Thomas uh
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um there
was um two concerns that you as the
prime sponsor I would like to address um
the the first one is that there's less
revenue for public education so I want
to um hear about the the direct impact
of that and then it was raised that that
there's a lack of reporting
requirements um from the assessors and
that was from the municipality so if you
could address both of those please
that'd be
helpful so I passed out or I made sure
that every member of this committee got
a copy of
the commission report that we generated
last
fall it was a significant Report with
over 40 different findings and several
different
recommendations and the findings in that
report indicate that there will be a
reduction in education trust fund Monies
from the exemption of these generators
from the utility property tax by about
$6
million but moving them to the
swept will actually uh recover most of
that
money in addition the report revealed
that there was currently a
110 million doll Surplus in the
education trust
fund so this led legislation will have
no impact on the funding of Education
short or long
term the other question you raised
was uh uh it was actually raised by
municipalities the reporting
requirements exactly right the reporting
requirement so this
legislation treats electricity
generators as manufacturers
and no other manufacturers in the state
are required to do the kind of reporting
that the
municipalities would like to see so we
didn't think it was necessary to force
these new this new class of
manufacturer to be different from all
the other manufacturers in the state so
we didn't require a reporting
requirement as the commission report
made above L clear the amount of public
information about electricity generation
facilities is
voluminous and assessors have access to
all that
information as they go about their work
of assessing these
facilities further
discussion representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman I'm still
confused about the effect on educ ation
funding uh as I read the fiscal note it
says that in fact um uh the ETF Revenue
will decrease by 5.36 million in FY 28
12.72-ounce money won't be going into
the ETF so I'm I'm I'm I'm concerned
that in fact education funding will
decrease even though swept isn't going
to change and I also understand that
we're we'd be moving these into the
denominator of how swept is calculated
so that in fact the rate for everybody
would go down but just the total amount
going into education it seems to me is
going to go down am I
misunderstanding yes the commission
discovered that in some towns swept will
recover more money with the addition of
these generators and in other towns it
might go down a little bit but um the
amount of money collected for
Education will go up overall as a result
of these generators being moved into
swept now it is true that the utility
property tax won't be making a
contribution to the education trust fund
but but uh the education trust fund
isn't the only place that
education uh Revenue comes into the
coffers of the
state but I mean what I see in the
fiscal note the bill keeps swept
constant so the amount going into swept
doesn't change I understand it may vary
from town to town but but the total
amount going into swept doesn't change
yet what's going into the ETF does
decrease that's what I'm I'm getting
hung up on that's because the education
trust fund is capped I think it's
363 million something like that
so if the education trust fund cap was
raised then that money could be
swept but it isn't the job of this bill
to raise that that cap so that would
that happens during the budget
representative Summers thank you Mr
chairman um just to add on to it I know
that many of us and it was a bipartisan
uh group of us from this committee that
attended many hours over the Department
of Revenue last year discussing these
very things and I know the big
stipulation there was how to handle
these different assessments of property
taxes with utility taxes compared and so
this would it pass out would ease this
whole issue that was that would
Troublesome last year between us and the
Senate if I remember
correctly further
discussion representative migy thanks um
I guess to for for the conversation
that's just been happening the thought
that I had is it's I guess it's
inevitable that the uh utility tax
donation to the education trust fund
would no longer be there because we're
eliminating it right so um I think there
was considerable work done to discuss
how that would operate in the towns and
in the budgets for the swept and I um my
understanding is that it'll be in many
cases it's expected to be a wash it's
it's not expected to be there will be
less money going into the ETF but I
don't think it'll be less overall
education funding um now that the
generators are paying the funds uh at a
different rate going into the
swept and I guess that's that's that's
the thing that I'm hung up on is I'm not
sure how the rate differs in that
whether it comes out as a plus or a
minus the money is not going into the
ETF that we can agree but the amount
that's going into swept from the
generators if it stays the same or if it
increases slightly to make up any
difference I don't think that's been
answered and if it wasn't the purpose of
this bill
to uh deal with the the cap on the
education trust
fund that is for either the Ways and
Means Committee or the finance committee
to deal with we made it abundantly clear
that and by the way to to be clear this
bill does not eliminate the utility
property tax it just exempts gener ERS
from paying it the utility property tax
is still going to be paid by utilities
and and those who own utility property
so and it's a considerable amount of
money as I recall from the the
commission report it's something like
43 million doar that's collected just by
the upt each year so
uh the bottom line here is that with 10
billion million dollar Surplus in the
education trust fund any impact that
this bill has on that fund will be
negligible it will be handled by that uh
Surplus so there there's not a negative
to uh passing this bill that exempts
these generators from the
seeing none I ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of ought to pass on
FN Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
scheller yes representative McGee yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
representative La Rochelle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman oose
yes 180 by a vote of 18 to zero the
committee adopts the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 696 FN without
objection we'll put this on the no we
can't put it on the uh consent calendar
so it'll be on the regular calendar I
will write the committee report for
House Bill
696 so with that we'll close the exec
session on House Bill
696 yes representative McGee we had um
we had uh agreed to put 567 on consent
but that also has an FN just that i' oh
it's an
it never
mind okay there will be a couple of
minutes delay while I go and
[Music]
shance right so apparently the uh
circulating
e
okay let me update everybody on what's
Happening we just got two bills back
from o
with requested amendments and the first
one we looked at we found errors in the
newly crafted
Amendment so I'm now I've now texted the
clerk to ask if we can adopt this with
corrections or do we have to get another
new
Amendment and so I'm waiting for an
answer for him this is on U house bill
FN so maybe we could just have a quick
work session on this amendment to see if
people see how how the committee feels
about this amendment in general and then
we can decide what to do about
correcting the Mis mistakes that we
found um U Mr chairman yes probably help
everybody if we could tell them where
the errors were that weren't caught on
on line 15
it says general court to prohibit that
764 line 15 page one the the intention
of the general court to take R of the
word prohibit and put in discourage and
the same thing on line 19 uh Air
Pollution Control geoengineering not
prohibited discouraged so both cases
two those are the two Corrections that
we would need to make and I'm asking the
clerk if we can just make those
Corrections and pass this amendment or
or if we have to get a new
Amendment no you can't make Corrections
you can adopt it and get a floor
amendment to fix it that's what Paul
Smith
suggests
so so so let's do that okay so let's
open an exact session then on House
Bill um
FN which has the current
title of prohibiting the intentional
release of polluting emissions including
cloud seaing weather modification
excessive electromagnetic radio
frequency and microwave radiation and
making penalties for violation of such
prohibit prohibition
plog to make a motion for to the
adoption of an
amendment thank you chair yes I would
like to make a motion to
adopt the
amendment believe it's
uh
677 0
677h yes yes thank you okay chair
recognizes uh representative
Bernardi second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt Amendment 764 FN
now it was brought to my
attention last week or the week before
that we actually have to have a motion
of
otpa first then we deal with the
amendment have to have have a motion
motion to OTP of OTP with the amendment
you're voting on the amendment all right
then you vote otpa if that passes or you
through yes representative n i I wasn't
really listening to to um representative
Bernardi the clerk uh so I don't know if
he already said this it's um Mr chairman
I make a motion ought to pass and I'd
like to introduce an
amendment that's how it goes okay
okay representative
Bernardi second by motion okay
so it's been moved that we
rule House Bill 764 FN to be worthy of
ought to pass as amended and now
representative n is recognized to
introduce an amendment oh actually I
wasn't I wasn't making the um the motion
I was just repeating what the clerk told
us from a previous meeting it's p we've
done it it's and myself okay ready all
right so the the amendment is on the
floor so what does the amendment
do the
amendment um significantly changes the
original Bill starting with the
title the title
now is discouraging the intentional
release of polluting emissions including
cloud CL seating and weather
modification that will be the new
bill and the rest of the bill is a
subset of an amendment offered by the
prime sponsor of the bill representative
fenza when she introduced the
bill we took um her Amendment and made
some changes to it
including changing the word prohib ited
to the word discourage in several
places so the bill now
discourages
geoengineering and says that no person
should engage in Geon geoengineering
activities including weather
modification stratospheric aerosol
injection or solar radiation
modification involving the intentional
release of polluting
emissions we retained from her earlier
Amendment a section that
exempts cloud seeding weather
drought and in her
Amendment on page two line four she
wanted the state to conduct a 14-day a
one month environmental review and we
changed that to 14 days because if this
is a drought
catastrophe then a one-month
environmental review seems maybe a
little
long and uh the amendment also gives to
Services the right to maintain oversight
activities although it doesn't
necessarily describe
entail and then the only real actionable
item that this amendment provides is
that the Department of Environmental
Services shall within 30 days of the
effective date of this section provide
notice to the following ENT entities
that geo geo engineering is discouraged
in lines
22 through
line line nine on page three list all
the federal bureaucracies that need to
geoengineering okay now I'm going to
recognize Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair and just uh
for one more change uh if you go to to
the first page on line
12 uh the original wording in the middle
of the sentence was harm to human health
and safety we replace that with the
phrase have unknown effects to human
same okay further discussion
representative PL uh thank you chair uh
for the clerk in the record uh could you
identify represented
patens
amendment I don't think it has been
noted we were disc discussing her
Amendment could we just identify it for
the
record that we're change you want the
number is that what you're ask yes
0214 you got that okay further
discussion representative Corman thank
you Mr chairman uh I'm just a little
confused what does it mean to discourage
the these Act activities and what does
it mean that no person should
engage what what are we actually saying
can and can't happen we're saying things
shouldn't happen we don't want them to
law good question representative Beres
thank you Mr chair um I also will be
voting against this uh Amendment and
Bill it's not clear what is enforcable
and are there any other examples of of
rsas that simply discourage something um
I mean it seems like this would make
more sense as a house resolution perhaps
instead of a state law thank
you just to address your point there are
lots of state laws that have no U
penalties or enforcement Clause that
prohibit
things further discussion representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um I
actually have a few few points to
mention about this bill number one is
the change on line 12 on page one um
saying that there's unknown effects to
human health well that comes in to
importance later on page two when they
do a a 14-day environmental study to uh
identify the harm to Public Health if
they're unknown I'm not quite sure how
you can identify them um number two is
the way that it is written on lines 23
and
24 um it talks about involving the
intentional release of polluting
emissions well that discourages all
planes over the state of New Hampshire
um because they all emit polluting
emissions um number uh the third thing
is um on page two line four and we
talked about this during the the hearing
but it says the state shall conduct the
this 14-day environmental review um who
in the state um we had talked about the
Department of Environmental Services but
this simply says the state and lastly
that 14-day I cannot get over that
because um in the town of marac where we
have P we've been waiting for nine years
to to uh find the environmental public
health and Wildlife harms of pest good
luck doing that in 14
days so I will be voting no on this
thank you okay further
Kaplan yeah thank you Mr chair I I also
will be bony against this bill I I have
a problem with the exemption for cloud
seating in case of drought I don't
understand that exemption it doesn't
seem to be based on anything we heard in
our public hearing about the
effectiveness or the Andor the need for
cloud seeding in case of drought are we
facing imminent drought are we facing
long-term drought do we know that and
what if effect would cloud seating have
on that drought is it an effective means
of countering drought do we know that
did we hear that I don't think we did so
I just don't it's just too vague and the
other thing I have a problem with is the
notification process to all these
federal agencies like is that re
recreating the wheel don't we already
have processes in place for our state
government to be in touch with the
federal government and in cases of you
know emergency drought or what have you
uh and isn't that doesn't that come
under the the chain of command that's
already in place so I I just I find this
bill problematic so I'll be voting
against
discussion representative
Harrington yeah I I look at this bill
and I have a hard time not almost
laughing um for example why in hell
would the N nuclear Regulatory
Commission care what our opinion on
geoengineering is in New Hampshire uh
the National Park Service there's no
national parks in New Hampshire we we
just seem to be blasting every Federal
agency they can come up with and I just
don't think it accomplishes anything and
so uh I I'll be voting against the
bill further discussion representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair I think the
bottom line for me is that uh the people
who originated this and who would like
to see it passed I do not believe that
even if this were to pass that they
would be satisfied with the outcome in
any way shape or form and this would
ultimately be an exercise in futility so
I'm against
this further discussion representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair so uh this
amendment with I think relatively small
changes is essentially the amendment
that the prime sponsor came up with uh
to the original bill which was
considered uh just totally out of
bounds
um I believe that the focus of this
amendment as well as her original
amendment that she
presented uh was largely to have two
things happen first the repeal of RSA
12f which is the second the penel
ultimate line on page three and uh the
the second thing is to basically make a
statement hence it probably should have
been a resolution but it wasn't it was
filed as a bill uh but make a statement
that New Hampshire stands against
geoengineering and blasts every Federal
agency that is known demand of that
information that's what this bill does
because that's what its purpose was um I
I believe it's appropriate to move
forward with it uh all otherwise we are
going to continue to see this bill in
other forms continue to come to
us further
discussion Vice chair Thomas thank you
Mr chair I I share uh my good friend %
of B's sentiment on this bill the
important thing on this bill is that it
does repeal RSA 12f and it
also uh puts wording in here that are is
a little more palatable in order to uh
get this bill passed um since we can't
really prohibit things that the federal
government might might want per se but
it does send a message we found out that
we could not change this bill into a
resolution it's just against the rule
so we decided on this language to uh do
exactly what the representative already
said which was make a statement and to
repeal uh 12f and that's why I'll be
supporting this
amendment further discussion
representative
Kaplan yeah I mean I agree this is a
better version than what we had in the
earlier Amendment and as I I think I
even mentioned to the prime sponsor at
some point if all she wanted to do is
repeal 12f I would be support of that
it's just all the other stuff that I
can't
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the question call the role
on the question of the adoption of the
ex Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington no
Representative bery no representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative rolds no
representative law relle
yes representative Swanson no chairman
Bose
yes four five six seven eight 28 n to uh
uh
seven seven eight nine no nine to nine
to 10 wait a minute 1 2 three four five
six seven eight nine 1 2 3 four five six
seven eight nine nine to nine n n okay
by a vote of nine to nine the amendment
fails so that will now bring us to the
question of the original motion which
was ought to pass Is there further disc
discussion on the motion of ought to
pass Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chairman uh without the adoption of this
all further
discussion of order uh representative
Matson on my account I had two NOS from
one from Harrington and one from Bry so
it was eight not 10 I mean
nine no was N9 to n
I'm not we had a a yes from representa
La
relle okay any further discussion needed
on the motion of ought to pass just a
question yes so um representative ner
moved ought to pass with Amendment no I
didn't no
no did oh okay okay
so so this motion is made by
representative
PL yes okay yes got it the motion
OTP any further discussion
needed I'll ask the clerk to call the qu
role on the question of OTP
introduced VI sh Thomas
no representative ner no representative
Harrington no representative Bry no
Representative bernardy no
representative PL yes representative
Summers no representative Matson no
Representative schneller no
representative McGee no representative
no represent ative Kaplan just a simple
no representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no representative La relle no
representative Swanson no chairman v
come okay by a vote of 1 to 17 the
motion of OTP fails is is there another
motion representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman I move
itl representative
McGee I second that moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of itl on House
needed seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of the
adoption of the motion of of itl on
Thomas um
yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL no
representative Summers
yes representative Matson yes
representative scheller yes
representative McGee yes representative
parshall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman Vose
yes 17 to
one by a vote of 17 to one the committee
adopts the motion of itl for House Bill
764 representative Corman will write the
committee report without objection we'll
put this on the consent
representative thank you chair yes I do
object I'll The Minority Report it'll go
on the regular
calendar so with that we'll close the
exec session on House Bill
764 so that gets us down to our final
bill for
FN
pardon uh so the next bill is House Bill
219 FN we'll open a exec session on that
relative to phasing
out the minimum electric renewable
and the chair recognizes representative
Harrington for a
motion trying to figure now we put the
bill in first or the amendment the otpa
first okay I move otpa to pass and I
offer Amendment and I offer
Amendment not to pass offer
Amendment uh
0678 H okay chair recognizes
representative Berney
I second that motion moved and seconded
that
we adopt the motion of ought to pass
0678 to House Bill 219 FN it was passed
out to everyone a little while ago does
everyone have a
copy no I do not have
that are there any other copies
that's what we
did I did not it was representative
lelle are there other copies over
there
219 okay there are other copies who does
not have a
copy please pass them along this way
please
the amendment number again
H and representative Harrington asked me
to go through this amendment to explain
exactly what it does it makes two
relatively major changes and several
minor changes
the two major changes are it
eliminates the first of the two major
changes is that it eliminates class two
standard the name of the bill changes to
relative to changes to the minimum
electric renewable portfolio
standard so as I said two major changes
one is the elimination of class class
two the other major change is a
reduction in
the obligation under class one
thermal and then there are some minor
changes so let's talk about the two
major changes first why eliminate Class
2 well it turns out that for years
utilities have not been buying class two
Rex
because the net metering credits they
receive give them enough Rex to satisfy
their class two obligations so they're
not buying them and therefore Class 2 is
not stimulating any
additional renewable
energy uh building build outs so by
removing the class
two class from the
RPS uh we can generate some
savings for rate
payers it looks like the elimination of
class two generates about $1.5 million
in savings for rate
payers the other change is uh on line
27 it reduces
the percentage of class one thermal to
1.7% beginning on August 1st of
2025 after which it shall remain
unchanged
and the reason for that change is
currently the
2.2% obligation for class one thermal
generates about
220,000 wrecks a year but the historical
record over the last 10 years is that
only about 50 to 60 or 50 to 70,000
wrecks have actually been produced T-Rex
thermal recks as they're
called so by reducing the oblation by
from 2.2 to
1.7% it'll save about 4 $4.2 million for
rate payers without having any
measurable effect on class one thermal
because there still are not enough
wrecks to being produced to satisfy the
obligation the minor changes in the bill
include the elimination of references to
class two in various sections through
throughout the the bill and
um another change that
that kind of jumps out at you is on line
eight in class one we defi redefined
wind energy to be wind energy except
that mandated by government procurements
and that's to
prevent offshore
wind uh from
overwhelming class one and making
the the reck in class one virtually
worthless which could happen if there's
a huge influx of offshore wind uh
credits another important change is on
page two starting on line 31 going down
to line 3
6 this section changes the acps for
class 1 3 and four from their current
levels
to levels that are about $2 above the
levels in Massachusetts and
Connecticut and the reason for that
change is to stimulate more recks being
satisfied here in New Hampshire instead
of going to U Massachusetts or
and
uh that change will also reduce the
amount of ACP payments going into the
fund by uh some amount an amount that
hasn't been really uh
determined the other change on page
three
on lines 16 through 19 are changes uh
that repeal the class two
references in the
bill and there's a couple of
other deletions that OS made like on
line four I'm just seeing this for the
first time line four on page three they
deleted an entire
sentence with regard to class 2
output so those are the changes that
this amendment
suggests and collectively they'll save
about $5.7 million for rate payers
without having any really negative
effects on Renewables
growth and it's interesting to point out
that just the other just last week it
was real revealed that Massachusetts our
29% of the average electricity bill is
now spent on public policy almost
30% of an electricity bill
is is going toward public
policy
and the citizens of Massachusetts are
quite upset with how much money is being
of their income that's going to to pay
on their electric bill for all these
public
policies Massachusetts also raised the
amount of money it's devoting to Energy
Efficiency from 4 billion to 4.5
billion and they touted that as a
reduction because originally they had
planned to raise it to five billion but
because they only raised to 4.5 billion
they said that was a half a billion
dollar uh reduction in their Energy
Efficiency
spending I think those are examples of
public policy that's gone off the rails
and is out of control and we don't want
that to happen here so we think these
are uh reasonable reforms to make to the
RPS and
[Music]
um I'm interested to hear what the rest
of the committee thinks so I'd open this
the floor to the discussion of this uh
this
amendment representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman thank you for that
explanation I have a couple of questions
but um when you mentioned Massachusetts
having a third of their bill going to
programs do you have information about
how much what percentage New Hampshire
is spending on
programs because I don't think anybody
has been complaining about this I know
we're always trying to solve for it but
that's my question now the exact number
in New Hampshire
is between 10 and
12% and the point I'm trying to make
here is that we have taken a much more
conservative approach yes uh to uh make
sure that we don't outrage our citizenry
by overcharging them for Public Policy
okay then uh let me follow on line 30 I
don't think you did highlight on page
two which is repealing the renewable
energy fund and then replacing it with
the language after that which basically
changes the classes and the amounts that
are paid per wreck um that renewable
energy fund from testimony that we
received this year in
hearing um usually puts out about
11% whereas 89% is private dollars in
the projects that we invest in in order
to have local sustainable energy in the
state that is sounds to me like a very
good investment in terms of we're not
we're not spending the kind of money
other states are we have been
conservative with the Investments that
we make but if this bill passes the
renewable energy fund is no more and so
that 11% that we put forward to help
people make the numbers work when they
do an upfront investment in a project
where they will not have an ongoing fuel
cost um you know the the whole point of
the program uh and the rec program as
well
is to incentivize having more investment
in those types of local sustainable
energy sources
so I I I do uh appreciate the argument
that you're making for the fact that we
don't want to
overspend uh on assisting but I have
actually had people when I'm knocking
doors complain that New Hampshire
doesn't have enough um help for people
who are trying to actually lower their
own energy bills right they they want to
know what programs we have so there must
be some kind of happy medium here but
you didn't mention that we're repealing
the renewable energy fund as well so
there'll be no more Investments if this
bill passes in the RF well I didn't
mention that because the bill doesn't do
that it makes some changes to the text
of the uh RSA 362 F10 which is the
section about the renewable energy fund
but it does not repeal
it just section
three AC
amount section six of the bill page two
starting on line
11 amends RSA 362 F col
10 uh to read as follows and you can
read the text it does
not eliminate or repeal the renewable
energy fund all it does is delete some
references to class
two so I'm not sure and then if you look
on page three lines 17 18 and
19 there are a couple of repeals there
but um none of those are I'm referring
to page two line 30 section 7 renewable
energy fund where it says RSA 362 f103
is repealed and Reena Ed so I'm looking
at that section
F10 yes but
f103 and f103 is the r ACP payment
section so there'll be no more ACP
payments by the utilities is that what
we're saying
no the the section is repealed and then
reenacted so it just changes the acps
from what they were before in the cas
case of class one it was $68 in the CL
case of Class 2 it
was $55 I think and class 4 it might
have been
$45 it just changes the amounts from
those numbers to the numbers that you
see here it doesn't repeal it it
technically it just uh reenacts it and
changes the numbers okay I'm looking at
it yes so it's replacing that section
section right replacing it and what are
those numbers based on those are ACP
payments and no what are the numbers
based on why are we changing them
they're based on Massachusetts
Connecticut and Rhode Island
acps which are
40 and um
35 uh for class 1 three and four
respectively and there is of course no
thermal energy in those States so is
that is that designed to reinvigorate
the Rex which are not yes yeah yes okay
thanks representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman not
really a question more of a request I
mean this to me is a pretty big change
and I'm having trouble wrapping my head
around it at least in in the time frame
that we have today so I would request
one of two things one is that we recess
the hearing to give us time to really
absorb this or the other is that we um
retain the bill so that we can actually
changes well this is an early bill so it
has to be done either today or
tomorrow um or or retained or retained
right um but it has to be done no later
than tomorrow motion on the floor to
pass right now we have a motion on the
floor
so uh representative McGee I I made a
note as I was looking through here
because it to representative corman's
point there are a lot of changes in here
to absorb and on page three I wrote
based on what um on line three a
sentence starts that says for the
purpose of estimation the department of
energy shall use a capacity Factor
rating of 20% for each class one
installation and again we are just we're
just pronouncing that and I don't know
if that's accurate if that's good if
that's what we should be doing if it's
helpful if it hurts that's existing
statute no
change that's already that text is
statute I I understand but again I I I'm
thinking if we're going to be revamping
this section I think we should
understand what we're putting in place
for capacity factors on uh because class
one is also new renewable installments
right so we could have much higher
capacity factors and maybe that language
is is is not uh adequate so I I just
would like to know that we're doing
something that's actually what we want
to be doing if we're going to be making
significant changes I know that's not a
change but I'm just saying it may need
changing and so I think we need some
answers before we just pass
it representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair uh as the new
guy here once again as very much a
process question
but uh I received a lot of mail on this
one as far it was
originally uh I'd like the changes that
were made and feel very positive about
them uh as far as process goes we had a
public hearing on the previous version
we don't do we need a public hearing on
this amendment given the level of
changes and how would that
work well house rules say that if you're
going to
no amend a bill
um amend a different section of law than
the original
Bill amended or the original Bill
addressed then you have
to that that Amendment could be ruled
non- gerine unless you held another
public hearing but this bill or this
amendment addresses the exact same
section of law as the original bill so
it is Germain to make an amendment like
this uh without having another public
hearing thank you Mr chair I I was
prepared to offer very stirring
Soliloquy on this but uh I have uh
decided that's no longer going to be
necessary based upon what I'm seeing so
far thank you
okay Rel
uh re let's go to representative Kaplan
first and then we'll come back to you
representative McGee so I I thank you Mr
chair I just have couple questions for
you uh correct me if I'm wrong this this
amendment
basically eliminates class
two and increases ACP payments second
question I do have a problem with
actually decreases ACP payments ACP
amounts oh it decreases the ACP amounts
but incre the amounts are higher than
the massachus in Connecticut and Rhode
Island ACB payments but they're already
higher than Mass they're already so it's
actually lower the ACB things okay thank
you for that clarification my second
question is uh on line eight wind energy
ex uh so you're you're adding the
language except mandated by government
procurements which government it seems
unclear and vague like what government
are you talking about the federal
government New Hampshire
government um any government any
government so you talk
China they're they're they're mandating
offo wind in some other jurisdiction and
we're going to say that's not going to
count for new ampire I'm just unclear
how that would even work well it's not
likely that a
Chinese wind farm would uh try to sell
Rex into New England's RPS Market but
wind farms off the coast of
Massachusetts Maine Rhode Island yeah U
if they try to sell Rex into the New
Hampshire Market we say no because we
don't want to get our Market flooded
with with class one Rex thank you
Goa additional comment representative PL
uh thank you chair uh I myself also over
the years had input from my constituents
and involvement in this and your
explanation on page one line
2728 of the amount of thermal Rex being
um used now I will be voting in favor to
off to pass thank
you further discussion representative
mcke my question was on that section as
well because I I keep reading it over
and over again but I don't know what the
impact is going to be I know you said
that there would be
savings um but on line 26 on page one of
the of well I'm reading I'm actually
reading the amendment right um it says
the set percentage shall be
4% in 2014 and then it goes up
2% uh each
year uh landing at 8% in 2016 and then
2% per year from 2017 through 2023 which
brings us up to the 2.2% which you
referred to and then beginning in the
summer of this year it's going to be
reduced back by 0.5% to
1.7% and I'm not sure what that does
because because my understanding from
our hearings was that class one was when
people are investing in new Renewables
right so if they want to put in a new uh
source of energy that would be an
expensive undertaking there it it's
we're going to be going backwards in
terms of what we're going to
um provide for folks who are making
value so this is pertaining to class one
thermal
yeah well I'm I'm thinking of um I'm
thinking of John Moses who came here
from was it Britain Lumber speaking
about the fact that they had just put
put in a new thermal unit that they
wouldn't have made that investment if
they didn't have the Rex that's what I'm
thinking of I'm thinking of the people
who came here and told us how valuable
it is because they have they have the um
the capacity and they have the energy
and then they have the Rex and that's
sort of what makes up the the fiscal
reality of whether they can do these
kinds of Investments so they want to
make the Investments but these types of
programs actually are supporting that
they
happen
and I don't know what will happen if we
are uh lowering the value at a point
when many people around us in our in the
energy economy are are you know
increasing their support for
fuel
diversity so right now the 2.2%
requirement obligates the utilities to
purchase about
220,000 T-Rex per
year reducing at to
1.7 will lower that obligation to about
170,000 t-rex per
year over the last 10
years the industry has produced
somewhere between 50 and 70,000
T-Rex so that falls well short of the
obligation that would be set by
reducing the utility obligation to
1.7% there'd still be plenty of room for
growth in
T-Rex while simultaneously saving about
million in cost to the utilities for
purchasing
either T-rex or acps if there are no
T-Rex to purchase thank you that's a
great explanation because I did take
notes when you were talking about that
before but I don't think I netted what
you just explained thank you you're
welcome representative
Harrington yeah I just like to remind
the committee what we're talking about
here we're talking about the electric
rate payers subsidizing people who burn
wood for industrial boilers there is no
benefit to the rate payers is they don't
see their electric bill go down because
there's no decrease in usage I don't
think there's anybody in New Hampshire
that said I've been using massive
amounts of electric space heaters to
heat my facility my factory whatever and
now I'm going to switch over to Wood
they were using Oil propane or gas so
now they're switching over to Wood and
someone who's struggling to pay their
electric bill plays pays a slightly
higher bill every month to subsidize
those industrial boilers so anything
they get they should be very very happy
with because they're getting free money
Hampshire representative McGee I know
when um when Mr nebling who's here today
submitted testimony to us which I have
with me he listed all the folks who are
you know currently invested in these
types of projects and my town ofus has
both the police station and the town
hall that they converted over to you
know thermal uh generation and what
they've done is they've lowered electric
bills for everybody in town
uh so I I mean people make these
Investments because it's less expensive
to operate these facilities and they're
trying to get to the place where they
can afford to make the investment so
that they can lower people's costs so
there's arguments on both sides it's not
just a one-sided argument didn't lower
my counts well they lowered Mine by a
lot and we also received stuff from the
Rye energy committee we had testimony
here saying how much millions of dollars
that certain uh constituencies and
municipalities in the state have lowered
their energy bills because of these
Investments how did the the town of
Hollis lower their electric bill by
putting in Wood Fired
boilers they converted from oil and it
was cheaper cheaper to run cheaper to
operate cheaper Fuel and and the cost
went down by hundreds of thousands of
dollars because the energy Committee in
our town tracks that stuff and reports
that stuff and I remember that the um we
were very excited because this they
promised that the savings would be
significant and the savings were
significant people were very happy so
your energy bill went down but not your
electricity bill
necessarily it's money I don't know what
to say like I mentioned before a lot of
places are looking at energy as energy
um how it's delivered
is um not as germine as whether or not
you're able to create efficiencies
sustainability um lower your dependence
for you know shipping stuff in that
maybe you won't be able to get when
there's a war or whatever um you know
there there's a value to us having more
reliability which we talk about a lot on
this committee and so I I I just think
you know it we're enabling people to
make the decisions they can make by
giving them just a little teeny bit of
what they need to invest to make it work
for themselves but there is money to be
saved and that money gets shared by the
people um who are investing in these
types of things and and so that's just
my example because my town is on that
list and it reminded me that I was aware
when we made those initial Investments
we were kind of early to make those
conversions but the savings have been
significant so who gets those savings
everybody it doesn't you know we all
have electric bills and we need
mechanisms in order
to uh you know make stuff happen right
we don't we don't have another way
to never mind won go into all that but
but I guess my point is it's not just uh
one for one that somebody invests in
something here and then somebody else
gets stuff taken out of their pocket
there's also somebody invests in
something here that lowers costs which
means that also affects people in the
positive the same way so the argument
goes both
ways I think representative Harrington
was talking specifically about
electricity costs but
his
point okay further
discussion representative
Kaplan thank you yeah I just wanted to
add that it might not be you know gerain
to the electricity bills but it
certainly is gerain to property taxes in
the towns that have taken advantage of
these projects so I mean that's as
representative McGee said money is money
but U the point I want I actual point I
want to make is um on class two
eliminating class two I know that you
know there's not enough re being
generated in class if any Rex generated
being in class 2 but what effect will
eliminating the entire class have I I'm
not sure we at least I don't have a good
handle on that in terms of going forward
are there businesses that would seek to
make those kind of investments in this
state and are we cutting ourselves off
from those opportunities I'd just like
to have some more information on
that so a lot of
class what would have been class two
recks are now claimed in class one
because class one also allows
new uh resources to be identified as
class one instead of class two so since
class two is is essentially saturated a
lot of new solar wrecks are actually
qualifying for class one so it's not
going to harm those new resources or
prevent them from taking advantage of
standard all right seeing no further
discussion since we do have a motion on
the floor I'm going ask the clerk to
call the role on the adoption of
amendment
FN Vier Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
repres representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative reyolds no
representative La relle no
representative
yes so I have vote of tendon 8 the
motion 0678 h is
adopted now we'll have a vote on the
motion of otpa need need to motion and
second okay representative
Harrington motion to ought to pass
for I make get the right bill number
here sorry am what is it 219 19 as
amended okay representative Bernardi
second the motion moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of ought to
pass as
FN any further discussion
needed representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um the only thing I'd like to
say is on the class two um I understand
that new solar projects would
potentially be eligible under class one
but I'm concerned about people who are
existing solar projects that would no
longer be eligible under the Rex and and
what kind of impact we would be having
uh for those Investments so I would
really like to know what we're voting on
before we make it into law that's
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of ought to
pass as amended on House Bill 219 FN
Vice shair Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parall no representative
Kaplan no representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas no representative Corman no
Representative rolds no representative
La relle no representative Swanson no
chairman Vose yes
108 by a vote of 10 to8 the committee
adopts the motion of ought to pass as
amended by Amendment
H so represent ative
um now I forgotten who made the motion
har representative Harington will write
the majority report will there be a Min
Minority Report there will
representative Swanson will write it
representative Swanson will write The
Minority
Report and I would need that by 5:00
p.m. tomorrow afternoon
thank you Mr chair no problem thank
you all right so we're done there we'll
close the executive session on House
Bill 219 FN that concludes our business
for today tomorrow morning at
10:30 we will have a full committee work
session
on four different
bills I believe it is or maybe five um
from 10:30 until noon then we'll break
it noon for lunch and then we'll come
back at 1:00 for another exec session on
those five bills four or five bills and
then that will conclude our work for
this
week next week we will meet on
Monday the 10th of March but we will not
meet on Tuesday the 11th Tuesday the
11th is 10 town meeting day and
the speaker of the house has basically
said we're shutting down the state house
that day so please don't schedule any
meetings for town meeting day so we will
not do any session on March 11th but we
will do an executive session on on the
10th we will have 11 bills remaining
after we finish our work tomorrow
afternoon so
whether we'll do all 11 on the 10th or
not uh I haven't decided yet we probably
will do them all even though it'll be a
long day um because we have to be done
by March 20th so we're getting kind of
close by March 10th so we'll probably do
them all on March 10th but there is a
possibility we might go to the following
Monday which would be the 17th are these
bills that have had hearings or haven't
every bill at this point has had a
hearing
we have no more bills to hear we now we
just need to make a decision on bills so
we've got a lot of important bills ahead
of us we've got House Bill 760 House
Bill
um other numbers that don't jump right
out at me but there are quite a few
significant bills that we still have to
deal with so we will have a work session
on the 10th followed by an exec session
it'll be a long day probably so plan on
being being here probably till 5: on
Monday March
10th anything else anybody needs to
bring to our attention Tom
representative flog uh thank you chair
uh this morning there was a request to
put the Blue Book numbers on record if I
um there we go house bill
266 the um the blue sheet
entries the online was three in support
three
opposed house resolution
15 the blue sheet had no input on
support nor oppos Don line had one in
support two oppos
House Bill
599 again blue sheet no one oppose no
one's supported online there was eight
in support three oppos uh thank you
chair okay thank you anything else
representative Corman uh yeah I just
want to remind people that we're going
to have a subcommittee work session uh
immediately following uh on HB 537 HB
539 and hb680 F
then and any member of the committee is
welcome to stay for the work
session but you don't have to but you
are welcome
to okay with that we're done thank you
tomorrow
e
folks we're going to begin the uh
subcommittee work session on the uh
three bills dealing with the residential
rates um so we have four of our five
subcommittee members here and
uh I'm just going to re recap what I
believe the key issue is which is
um
because certain Services of the
associations are built build to a
business address they are build at a
commercial rate rather than a
residential rate yet those services are
services that typically would be uh if
in a
homeowners uh property would be build at
a residential rate so a well Septic
System Sprinklers for your garden uh
washing dryer machine if was in a in a
sub integreated facility those normally
would would be homeowners or
expenses they' all be build residential
rate not a commercial right and uh we
have three bills that essentially are
focusing on that same common subject um
so uh the purpose of the subcommittee is
to
evaluate what action um can or should be
taken on on this
um I'm going to
uh start with uh
one potential modest proposal and there
are others
here
um one proposal would be having someone
named in the in the uh
Association as a named uh physical
person to have that bill show
up in their
name um
that would then automatically by the way
utilities Bill be built at a residential
rate rather than a commercial rate
because it's not a business
name that that is the biggest objection
from the uh utilities about uh um in
dealing with this issue if if they are
required to sort through and
identify
commercial business names that now need
to be built at a residential rate that
that that's a major
software program or billing program
reconstruction that is going to cost
them a lot of money um and we hear that
every time we pass legislation that
tries to influence um anything that
impacts billing
so um to do such I've asked whether the
department energy could be a named party
to send out such a letter to all
associations they've been lukewarm on
that
proposal um but they they could do that
and we have a list or a list of
501c4 entities could be generated that
doesn't name those entities that are not
registered with the Secretary of State
there are about a 100 that are with the
secretary of
state so with that
I'm acknowledge representative Corman
who has uh some words to offer to this
session and a another potential
alternative thank you representative
bernardy am I supposed to call you Mr
chairman no okay thank you
representative bernardy so you don't
have a gavel so I have nothing
here yeah so uh just to to give um
uh where where I feel like we're at
we're really talking about well and or
septic meters so electric meters for
well or
septic that are in homeowners
associations where they are
shared by more than one unit so it's
really just well in septic that we're
trying to talk about with these bills I
know you mentioned a few other things um
these bills are
this this concept went to the Commerce
Committee last year and there was all
sorts of push back on anything that
could be considered a common area like a
sprinkler so it so that's that's why
we've tried to restrict it to just
shared well shared septic that are
serving only residential units so as you
identified there were there were two
related issues here one being because
the bill is going to the HOA
it's being built at a commercial rate
even though the use is 100% residential
by 100% residential units and then the
other issue is how it's actually paid
for because when it's build to the HOA
the HOA builds all the units so that
people who are not on the shared well
and septic are actually paying a part of
the bill for the shared well and
septic so that's that's what we're what
we're trying to deal with is have just
the units with the shared well and
septic pay for the shared well and
septic and not have it spread across the
entire uh
condominium okay so th those are the
issues um I know that one of the
Condominiums involved uh has Unitil as
their supplier they've tried to work
with Unitil to get this dealt with and
that they haven't gotten anywhere with
it which is why they have asked for a
legislative
solution so I did uh I I have offered an
amendment um that I worked on with
representative Manos the prime sponsor
of these three bills uh she and I worked
on this amendment and I can go through
it whenever you'd like me
um I think that's fine I I I know uh Mr
sweat is here who can also offer us some
uh information about costing
differentials and what they really mean
so I'm going to acknowledge uh Mr sweat
to um just quickly review that and you
provided us with a package of
information
well thank you very much I would like to
point out that in both the Tariff
regulations Schedule D and schedule
G2 it does not reference uh at all the
bu where you're bilding to it talks
about domestic use and non-domestic use
and those are the two criteria that
we're really talking about in the
tariffs there is really nothing about
shared meters or how you Bill it or
anything like that it's domestic or
non-domestic use it's the purpose of the
electricity okay let's get on to what I
handed out I think the most important
thing is on page two and if you look at
this there are columns and these are
household units 25 Vineyards seven
Woodside and two Vineyard and it shows
under the G2 rates the electric power
the electric charges for these rates and
these are the delivery cost only uh down
to said down to Total delivery charge
the supplier charge once again is a
Marketplace charge we have 19 people
competing for uh suppliers the the uh
delivery charge is a franchise and
really it's the responsibility of the
franchise holder to properly assign to
properly assign the Tariff rates for
what use it is either domestic or
non-domestic anyway if you get down to
the very bottom line where it says total
build you'll see for 25 Vineyard it's
$515 that's an actual billing and it's
included in your package if you go over
to the right under the
d25 the total bill if it were a consumer
rate is
$302 and you can see this for the
Woodside also and for the uh uh Woodside
and the two Vineyard the main charges
are really in the customer charge where
the domest where the uh commercial rate
is
$29.19 per meter the domestic rate is
$16.22 per meter there is a demand
charge for the uh commercial rate of
$12.13 that demand charge is required
for one kilowatt hour if you you use
less than 1 kilowatt hour you would be
still charged for a full kilowatt hour
if you go up under the G2 section where
it says meter demand and you see under
25 Vineyard they didn't use a full
kilowatt hour but they were charged a
full kilowatt hour if you go to seven
Woods side they did not use a full
kilowatt hour they were charged a full
kilowatt hour so those are the two areas
where the main charges are the uh demand
charge and the meter charge those two
areas they are delivery charges and that
is where the major discrepancy is now
eversource estimates that 600 kilowatt
hours is what a residential customer
uses I mean we are talking about if you
look at the top here the kilowatt hours
used for the septic system is 82 33 and
40 for a billing period the average
kilowatt hours used in a building power
period for the septic is 64 kilowatt
hours not even close to 600 kilowatt
hours and if you have look for uh if if
this was going to be a commercial rate
those kilowatt hours would be
substantially more than what they are
what they are now these the rate has not
been properly assigned for this purpose
domestic or non-domestic I would also
say that every source which said they
don't have the resources to to do this
Rivers Source had revenues in 2024 of
close of $1.9 million and paid a
dividend of roughly 4% I would think a
company like that does have the
capability and the resources to come up
with a plan where they could
differentiate
between uh uh the residential and
domestic customers and this is a very
limited one it's limited to septic it's
limited to pump water and uh I think
it's quite doable thank you thank
you does anyone else have uh comments
they would like to make before this
subcommittee
yeah good afternoon Representatives my
name is Eric
shanesy I'm an attorney I represent
representing I practice representing
condo associations that's the single um
focus of of my personal practice been
doing it for some time now I'm a partner
of the law for Mar and Shan and Udi we
represent an excess of 100 cond
associations in New Hampshire and
hundreds more in in Massachusetts I'm
admitted in both jurisdictions I'm a
member of Community Association
Institute CI and the New England chapter
of that I'm a member of the new of the
CI legislative action committee for New
Hampshire and also for Massachusetts and
I'm a co-chair of the attorney's
England we look at this from a legal
perspective uh of course
and the proposed uh
Amendment um to the statute that is 356b
talking about section
45 uh we you know as a practitioner
support this amendment it'll it assigns
a residential rate for these limited
purposes of the septic and Wells to
residential Condominiums um and it does
it in an equitable manner wherein the
units that utilize those Services pay
for those Services which is consistent
with the the overall framework of the
condominium statute so
um which is the the current existing
section 40 section 45 sub paragraphs 2
and three I'm happy to address the
specifics of those sections um but one
of the difficulties I would suggest that
that I see as a practitioner in this
area is finding uh and addressing
solutions that are Equitable and fair
where for some reason one unit owner is
being charged an amount for which they
receive no benefit in this proposed
legislation seeks to remedy that at
Dynamic so um thank you thank thank you
for coming uh I just want to make sure
that we all
understand what it is that currently
could inhibit
a condo association an
HOA from doing the type of billing that
we're talking about here where where the
chargeback would be divided among the
various units
and my understanding is that it depends
on how what What's called the
condominium instruments in uh 356b call
45 and in paragraph two of the existing
law it says to the extent that the
condominium instruments Express so
provide and then it goes on so if the
the condominium instruments don't
provide for that then they don't have
the ability to do this charge back is
that correct so let's let's break that
down a little bit so under section under
paragraph two of section 45 it says that
the condominium instruments have the
authority so this be the Declaration of
condominium and the bylaws could in
theory charge back to the unit owners
that portion here the the well and
septic to those units that receive that
benefit it has to be stated in the
condominium instruments if it is not
then we look at paragraph three which
says all these charges shall be assessed
to all unit owners so we have to look at
this in both context paragraph two
creates the possibility but it then
defers to the governing documents for
the association if the drafter of the
instruments did not contemplate this or
wasn't thorough then you the def fault
to paragraph 3 which would kick in which
says that all unit owners are paying for
thank you m committee members my name is
Zoe Manos I represent stratum which is
where The Vineyards is located and where
dick sweat lives I wanted to just
address the issue of uh the proposed
solution of the meter simply being put
in the name of individual homeowners um
I think that that's not a practical
solution um I believe that The Vineyards
tried to do that with um with Unitil and
uh Unitil refused to do that but I think
even beyond that even if the meter um
were in the name of the of individual uh
individual unit owner you would still
have the problem of two
units uh I believe Unitil was also
further not willing to if two units were
sharing one meter to put it in the name
of both Bob Smith and Clara Jones they
wanted it in the name of one or the
other but in either case you would have
the problem of then two unit owners
potentially squabbling over who owes
what is the bill paid is the bill not
paid etc etc and I think that that's a
pretty predictable situation that would
arise and in addition at The Vineyards
specifically I think there are 22 if I
remember correctly 22 paired meters so
you would then have
possible a deterioration in
relationships and unpaid bills and Etc
so I don't think that that's a uh
realistic solution and that's another
reason that the legislation is needed to
address this problem thank
yeah and and to add to what
representative Manos said you know I'm
thinking of a situation where um you
know again we have two units let's say A
and B A is the uh the address that the
bill goes to a moves out C moves into
where a was and C doesn't want to be the
record holder uh you I just I just feel
like this is um there could be all sorts
of sticky situations that can engender
animosity
yes thank you everybody has a copy
and the draft Amendment yeah you get a
copy
all right yeah so okay thank you so this
draws from uh from the three bills that
we considered as well as just other
ideas representative madis and I had
talked for quite a while yesterday I I
drafted something and then we figured
out how to make it better so in
think two of the bills in 537 and
539 uh there was something uh akin to
section one of the draft except that I
think it was not in the right place it
was almost in the right place um so this
idea of a statement of the purposes for
which the condominium and each of the
units are intended and restricted as to
use and then adding language and whether
any commercial or business enterprises
are permitted in the original bill it
was about the limited common areas and
whether any commercial or business
enterprises are permitted and here it
seems like it because we're really
talking about the individual units and
well and septic for those units it seems
like this is the right place to put it
in sub paragraph H instead of which sub
paragraph it was in before which was um
where are we here uh e was in sub
paragraph E
before and then uh in I think think it
was in 680 uh section two uh that
language not exactly the language you
see here but something similar appeared
in 680 but it was actually in RSA 378
which is about the public
utilities and what we realized is this
uh chargeback has nothing to do with the
public utilities it has to do with the
operation of the
HOA so instead instead of putting it
into RSA
378 we think that it actually should go
into RSA 356b which is about condos and
in particular into section 45 and I did
give everybody a copy of uh section 16
and section
45 and um and in fact we were just
talking about paragraph 2 of 45 and
paragraph 3 so what what we're
suggesting is let's um add a new
paragraph 3 rumber the existing 3 to
four and say that regardless of the
condominium instruments the cost for the
shared meter usage for the septic
systems and well pumps shall be charged
back only to the residential units that
share each meter even if the homeowners
association is the customer of the
public utility or Rural Electric
Cooperative and we wanted to make sure
that we included Rural Electric
cooperatives in case there are condos
served by the New Hampshire Electric
Co-op and the chargeback shall be
divided among these units ensuring that
the cost is equally split according to
the number of units sharing the meter
that language was in uh in 680 um with
one typo corrected here so so our
thought was that this really belongs in
the condo chapter not in the utility
chapter
um yeah we might need to do that might
to
do
supp states um oh no actually wait a
minute no um because they're not they're
not the distributor right they're not
who who's doing the billing right the
the actual billing is coming from one of
co-op okay I guess there are the
municipal power
companies yeah
all right so we might need to adjust
cover yeah okay good thank you and then
let's see um section three actually was
in I forget which one of the other bills
but it's essentially the same thing um
saying that the uh electric rate
schedule of a public utility filed with
the commission and commission being the
Pu shall ensure that condominium
associations under
356b which do not permit commercial or
business enterprises are charged the
same rates as condominium res
residential units for domestic septic
and well pump electric usage so really
just specifying it to that and ensure
that the billing for all such
residential units is at residential
rates even if the HOA is the customer
and even if shared meters are used so
and that's in 378 so it's in the public
utilities
and then uh section
four is um in 362 which is also about
public utilities if you look very
carefully in paragraph two in the fifth
line there's a a bolded Edition right in
the middle of the Fifth Line 378 col
6-a which is what we create in section
three so just updating that and then uh
adding uh actually the uh yeah in fact I
I should say that 362 is also about uh
Rural Electric co-ops so section three
or paragraph three is really the same
language as before but for a Rural
Electric
Co-op but you're you're point about um
getting any other distribution or B
biller uh yeah we that's good point sure
good afternoon one of these days I'll
know whether or not to push that button
when I sit here um first of all uh thank
you for the opportunity to speak and
apologies for not being at the public
hearing I I would have been uh we had
thought that this wasn't necessarily A
Unitil specific issue and as the hearing
progressed it we came up a lot and had I
foreseen that I would have been here so
we we'll blame the new guy as far as
that goes and lesson learned
ever no and I I saw that and I
appreciate that um I I don't know how
much I can say that will be helpful but
I did uh follow up with our customer
service folks to get the background in
terms of our own specific tariffs and at
least be able to explain uh what our
position has been throughout this and
and that may or may not be helpful um
effectively uh our tariff uh which
governs how we organize these rate
classes uh has effectively there's two
specific categories we're talking about
here we have what's called our domestic
uh rate and then we have what's called
uh the general rate which has been
called the commercial rate but just to
be specific there it's specifically
referred to as the general rate within
our tariff the domestic rate and I
pulled it up here on my laptop just to
make sure I'm seeing the language
correctly uh specifically refers to
metering on individual private dwellings
and individual Apartments so our tariff
specifically outlines that if you have a
meter and it's going to a specific unit
and everything that's feeding that unit
is for that unit then it's part of the
domestic rate the general service rate
and we have a small general service rate
and we have a large general service rate
uh specifically says it's for all
purposes meaning if it doesn't fall into
that very specific domestic rate then
it's metered under our general rate
which is lists with the specific rates
and the charges and the uh demand
charges that exist so our tariff is
designed specifically to try to account
for different kinds of uses uh be that a
bus business be that a meter that's
specifically looking at a well pump or a
septic pump so the way our tariff is
written the general service appears to
be where this would live effectively and
from our customer service team's
perspective consistency was the big
thing we needed to look at so if we're
doing it here and we're doing it over
here we want to make sure that the same
uses throughout our system are governed
the same way so that's effectively how
we got to the solution we got to on this
uh we did seek guidance from the
Department of energy when this came up
uh we were told we were interpreting our
tariff correctly so that's effectively
where we are on this I I wanted to
provide that background at minimum to
show that that's how our tariff is
interpreting this specific issue um in
regards to the amendment that was shared
uh one of the questions I would have uh
just in trying to understand it uh in
terms of how that bill gets
redistributed within the condo
association uh that would be a key
question that I would have that I want
to bring back to my folk so we
understood what the potential impact of
this bill would be uh is the idea among
this that because it's effectively the
homeowners association or the condo
association and what they is governing
them is changing is this billing
happening beyond the meter so to speak
so in other words we would continue to
build a meter as per our tariff and then
the condo association would be
redistributing that after those billing
occurred or is the idea that our billing
department would need to be implementing
some sort of new uh process which could
theoretically have cost Associated so I
don't know if if that's part of this
conversation that would be helpful
feedback that I could bring back to our
this so good
question uh the way that I believe
represent Madness and I think of this is
that what would change would be the
Tariff that you're charging on these
shared meters so you know for the shared
well shared septic instead of being
built at The General commercial rate it
it would be build at the residential
rate where the bill would go would not
change so the bill would still go to the
HOA and then the HOA would say okay this
uh bill is for these two units we're
going to build them so that doesn't that
part of it doesn't change you're still
building the HOA all that would change
rate so in defining your three classes
your domestic and your yeah two generals
uh is is that based on any statutory
construction or is that just the uh the
rules that Unitil came up with as part
of you know defining how they're going
to do billing sure uh well first of all
there are more than three rate classes I
should just point that out for the
record we have other rate classes time
of use rates rates for electric vehicles
those are the relevant rates for this
particular conversation uh the way the
Tariff is written in terms of that
general service rate we believe that
based on the way that our overall
tariffs are written and going through
rate cases with the Public Utilities
Commission this usage meaning a metered
septic pump or a metered well pump is in
the appropriate rate class for that
usage so you want your rate categories
to properly identify the kind of usage
that is occurring for that usage so in
this particular case if it's a metered
septic pump whether that's for-profit or
nonprofit it lives within this
particular rate class that's that's the
overall design and the overall concept
ultimately when we go before the Public
Utilities Commission to you know have a
rate you know have any kind of rate
review that would be an opportunity to
look at those tariffs and see if you
needed to further clarify or Define
ultimately what those definitions are so
under our existing definitions which
have been approved we believe that this
is currently appropriately uh accounted
for anytime we go before the P that
there's an opportunity to look at that
and review it so by Statute we Chang
that you would move it from General one
or what the lowest group to
domestic in theory yeah I mean that
would be ultimately uh our regulatory
folks would be able to provide better
but yeah anytime you move any specific
entity from one group to another group
then you go before you know that that
rate class and then effectively those
rates get redistributed because the
costs are still going to be the costs
across the system so you have a move
effectively changes that and then the
redistributed right yeah and I
understand what you're saying uh I would
just say a couple of things one is that
given that what we're talking about are
are uh meters that are purely serving
you residential units it just seems like
residential rates really ought to apply
and as far as the uh the
redistribution I would say that the that
we have a problem right now which is
that the uh the the payments are
distributed the wrong way in that
residential units are being are paying
the commercial rates when they should be
paying residential rates so I think what
we're trying to do is undo this
incorrect way of of assessing the The
Meters no I I very much understand that
I can only say that our rate definitions
aren't necessarily residential and
Commercial our domestic rate is specific
to individual residential dwellings and
understood does anybody else have
much so yeah so I I will look into
um seeing what else we need to do with
section two in terms
of ensuring that we cover
everybody yes I I hope I can work with
maybe the department of energy to get a
an idea of of what we could do with with
amendment
right
great
day
e